Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu raum zeit dem podcast über raumfahrt und andere kosmische angelegenheiten mein name ist tim und ich begrüße alle zur sechsundachtzigsten sendung hier in unserer reihe
und ja nachdem wir uns beim letzten mal in richtung sonne aufgemacht haben mal zu gucken
wie es da eigentlich so ist kehren wir wieder zur erde
zurück und schauen uns mal das an was auch sonst alles so zur erde zurückkehrt oder überhaupt das erste mal hier fuß fasst konkret möchten wir sprechen
über meteorit beziehungsweise konkreter über die meteoriten also das was letzten endes bei uns auf der erde landet und was man darüber,
lernen kann und dazu begrüße ich zunächst einmal mein gesprächspartner nämlich ansgar grisham schönen guten tag.
Herr sie sind beim naturkundemuseum in berlin mit der wunderschönen berufsbezeichnung christus das musste ich erst mal nachschlagen im prinzip bedeutet das so viel wie,
kurator kann man sagen oder.
Ja das ist richtig also die großen sammlung des museums für naturkunde haben alle einen wissenschaftlichen leiter,
kurator christus wie haben sie es nennen möchten der ist zuständig dafür dass die sammlung wissenschaftlich bearbeitet wird,
auch dafür zuständig das material für forschungszwecke zur verfügung gestellt wird auch für ausstellungen ausleihen und selbst natürlich daran zu arbeiten.
Fangen wir doch mal mit ihnen selbst erstmal an,
haben sie schon immer so wissenschaftliche karriere im blick gehabt oder quereinsteiger und wollte eigentlich musiker werden.
Also ich habe ganz klassisch geowissenschaftler studiert würde man heute sagen mineral logie damals war das noch getrennt mineral logie geologie,
ich habe auch sehr bodenständig im bayerischen wald meine diplomarbeit gemacht und bin dann ans institut für planet der universitäten münster gekommen,
und seitdem haben mich die außerirdischen proben nicht mehr losgelassen also ich habe meine doktorarbeit da geschrieben postdoc und bin dann neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig also vor dreiundzwanzig jahren nach berlin ins naturkundemuseum gekommen.
Direkt und nicht wieder gegangen weil es da so schön ist.
Und nicht wieder gegangen weil es da so schön ist und immer schöner wird.
Was muss man denn
so fünf haben auf das naturkundemuseum ich meine typischerweise hört man mal so museum nimmt man sich so ja okay und da steht irgendwie altes zeug hinter den vitrinen und das war's dann und da kann man so ein bisschen rumlaufen das entspricht ja nicht ganz so der wahrheit denn
museen an sich aber ich vermute auch gerade im besonderen das naturkundemuseum ist halt extrem in den wissenschaftlichen prozess mit,
eingebunden was was passiert dort und was ist da ihre rolle dabei.
Also historisch gesehen muss man ja sagen dass das museum für naturkunde teil der humboldt-universität war und als solches auch gegründet wurde der berliner universität damals,
und die drei institute planet paläonthologie mineral und zoologin,
waren integraler bestandteil der universität ist das wir haben immer volle universitäts- forschung gehabt und haben das bis heute noch das heißt wir haben hochschullehrer wir haben leute die unterrichten wir haben studenten,
und es ist ein richtiger wissenschaftsbetrieb das museum für naturkunde hat als er seine mischgeschlechter das heißt wir haben die ausstellung natürlich alle kennen das die großen saurier die das,
publikum anziehen die kids begeistern aber es ist ein forschungs museum.
Das wissenschaftlich arbeitet und auch diese wissenschaftlichen ergebnisse dem der gesellschaft zur verfügung stellt in den diskurs tritt um darüber zu reden also keine wissenschaft im elfenbeinturm sondern in dialog mit den menschen und der gesellschaft.
Das ist ja auch ein sehr beeindruckendes gebäude wenn man da reinkommt insbesondere dieser teil ich weiß gar nicht wie man den nennt wo die ganzen,
fischer in formaldehyd eingelegt wunderbar präsentiert sind man kann also drumherum laufen und sieht diese unfassbare riesige sammlung an,
allem möglichen getiere ich weiß gar nicht was da alles noch gelagert wird
das ist ja sozusagen auch bewusst so gemacht dass es sowohl wissenschaftlicher speicher ist aber man den eben auch sehen kann.
Richtig also es ist ein archiv das hat diese archiv funktion diese gerade ansprechen es wird gezeigt das ist material was aber auf jeden fall für forschungszwecke zur verfügung steht und sie werden sich wundern auch so ein material wird wird ausgeliehen,
dass viele sind solche typen materialien das heißt da ist eine art oder eine gattung zum ersten mal beschrieben worden überhaupt weltweit das ist also referenz material,
und was momentan ganz stark ist dass diese objekte digital erfasst werden.
Und das passiert weltweit dass die großen museen sich diese daten gegenseitig zur verfügung stellen,
damit leute eben nicht mehr nach london reisen müssen obwohl es natürlich ganz schönes mal nach london zu reisen sondern über datenbanken zugreifen können auf auf die informationen die sie für ihre forschung benötigt.
Digitalisierung ist ein schwieriges thema,
da muss man sich ja dann auch auf entsprechende datenstandards et cetera einigen wie wie findet das staat gibt gibt's sozusagen diese standards schon oder ist es museum auch selbst in der entwicklung der derselben mitbeteiligt.
Die großen naturkundemuseum europas und der vereinigten staaten auch weltweit arbeiten gerade an solchen standards und diese standards sind völlig unterschiedlich wenn man zum beispiel auf mineral logisch oder geowissenschaftler objekte schaut im vergleich zu biologischen zoologischen,
da gibt's völlig unterschiedliche begriffe,
typen gattung arten die erfasst werden das geht ja hin bis zur drei bis zum drei d scannen von solchen objekten und viele historischen sammlung arbeiten mit karteikarten,
das heißt er ist ein weiterer schritt zu gehen von der karteikarte hin bis zu datenbanken und da liegt noch einiges an arbeit vor uns das museum hat aber dezidiert geld dafür bekommen die es zu tun.
Und das wird jetzt unsere hauptaufgabe in den nächsten zehn jahren sein die sammlung digital zu erfassen,
beginnen mit bestimmten datensätzen die definiert sind und wieder erweitert werden können aber diese basis und grunddaten setzen werden jetzt erstellt und erfasst,
bis hin zu barcodes diese einscannen können und wissen wo das objekt gerade ist und sie sehen wenigstens ein paar informationen woher wer hat's gefunden was ist es natürlich,
das ist das ist eine große herausforderung bei diesen mengen von dreißig millionen objekten immer sie zahlen die sogenannte wird.
Aber es erhöht natürlich den mehrwert enorm weil man ja auch in gleicher hinsicht auch auf die ganzen,
funde in anderen museen auch zugreifen kann und in dem moment wo es dann halt allgemein beschrieben ist also man sich auf die entsprechenden standards geeinigt hat
kann man ja im prinzip aussehen so ah okay alles klar hier fehlt uns im prinzip noch dieses kleine steinchen in unserem mosaik und gucke mal das liegt da drüben auf der anderen seite des atlantiks vielleicht sogar rum schauen wir uns das doch mal genauer an.
Absolut das ist ja der sinn der mehrwert wird dramatisch erhöht dadurch es ist natürlich so dass in bestimmten fachdisziplinen man schon weiß wo was liegt unter kollegen aber das ist jetzt natürlich völlig andere ansatz das so breit aufzustellen.
Jetzt haben sie da verschiedene hüte auf das mit dem christus hatte ich ja schon beschrieben sie sind aber auch noch leiter des labors für transmissionswärmeverlust dronen mikroskopie,
deutsche sprache bringt immer wieder hervorragend wort ungetüm hervor was muss man sich darunter vorstellen.
Da muss man erstmal sagen dass das eine nicht aktuelle webseite ist weil wir dieses labor ja ja.
Schon geschlossen haben ja.
Wirklich ernsthaft das war ein gerät was wir in unserer neunzig gekauft haben was dann irgendwann wie man so schön sagt out of service geht und war defekt sodass wir das geschlossen haben und,
ganz kurz was es ist wenn sie sich normales elektronenmikroskop vorstellen da schießt man ja mit elektronen auf eine probe und man schaut sich die elektronen an die reflektiert werden transmissionswärmeverlust die probe so dünn dass die elektronen dadurch geschossen werden,
das schöne ist dass es hier im berliner umland umfeld einige solche geräte gibt die sind nicht ganz nicht ganz preiswert und man braucht natürlich auch die expertise von leuten
so dass wenn wir das benötigen für unsere forschung wir durch kolorationen durch zusammenarbeit dass sie uns reinholen.
Aber sie sind natürlich nach wie vor zuständig für die meteoriten sammlung das heißt das naturkundemuseum hat da eine größere menge an material,
herumliegen wie groß muss man sich da diese sammlung so vorstellen.
Also es ist im vergleich das ist die kleinste sammlung im haus also verglichen mit meinen kollegen die schmetterlinge oder oder andere objekte kuratieren aus in etwa zehntausend stück.
Zehntausend bruchstücke von planetarium körpern die auf die erde runtergefallen sind ist eine der größten der welt,
und das schöne ist an dieser sammlung dass sie von den typ von dem material her sehr repräsentativ ist wenn man so gesicht klassen anschaut was gibt es denn für unterschiedliche meteoriten wir haben fast alles.
Das ist natürlich für unsere forschung sehr wichtig wir haben einen großen anteil historische objekte.
Also material das zum beispiel von alexander von humboldt an das museum kam.
Einiges davon ist in der öffentlichen ausstellung sichtbar anderes liegt in meinem büro also in der sammlung und wir haben aber auch sehr moderne meteoriten.
Pfunde die gesammelt wurden wo also neues spannendes material in die sammlung kommt an dem wir selbst arbeiten und wo kollegen natürlich auch material anfragen.
Vielleicht sollte man an der stelle nochmal die technologie klar ziehen weil ich denke das wird oft ein wenig verwechselt also man hat halt,
asteroiden kometen etcetera alles was halt da draußen rumfliegen unterschiedliche charakteristika hat und danach erstmal zumindest aus der ferne unterschieden würden hat ja auch festgestellt wenn man hinfliegt so,
verschmelzen die unterschiede die man vorher so gesehen hat dann schon wieder ein wenig das hat man ja hier auch zuletzt als wir die maske mission besprochen haben wurde das klar,
in dem moment wo allerdings so ein objekt
in die erdatmosphäre eintritt und zu einer sternschnuppe wird also ein meter diesen eintritt macht und das was halt am ende auf dem boden liegen bleibt oder halt im meer je nachdem wo es runterkommt
das bezeichnet man als meteorit sprich sie haben die ganzen meteoriten rumliegen das ist also all das was quasi vom himmel gefallen ist,
woher weiß man denn da überhaupt dass das vom himmel gefallen ist.
Im besten fall hat man ja beobachtet wie es viel also viele der in mitteleuropa gefunden meteoriten sind beobachtete fälle also wir unterscheiden grundsätzlich zwischen einem meteoriten pfund und einem meteoriten fall,
das ist auch relativ leicht zu erklären wenn sie so einen schwarzen stein haben und gehen jetzt mal raus auf die straße und sammelt alle schwarze steine auf bitte nicht tun sag ich immer
weil das ist auch teil meiner arbeit dass also mitbürger und mitbürgerinnen kommen und meinen ein meteorit gefunden zu haben,
in den dreiundzwanzig jahren in denen ich jetzt im hause bin habe ich nicht einen einzigen meteorit auf diese weise bekommen weil es einfach sehr unwahrscheinlich ist hier einzufinden passiert aber es ist sehr.
Mittlerweile oder generell.
Generell also in zentraleuropa wie gesagt meistens meteoriten fälle beobachtete,
feuer schweif knall runtergekommen aufgesammelt das ist der idealfall das ist natürlich insgesamt gesehen der geringste anteil von meteoriten das meiste sind funde im wesentlichen stamm die aus heißen und kalten wüsten,
heiße wüste bei der gänge begriff also zum beispiel aus der aus nordafrika,
ich sag das mal so unscharf und es ist auch genauso gemeint also nordafrikanische länder von marokko algerien libyen westsahara niger sudan alles mögliche der große vorteil ist dass es eine helle oberfläche.
Und ich meine jetzt nicht die dünen sahara da findet man natürlich nichts weil das mit verweht sondern es sind kalt plateau auf dem man ganz normal mit dem auto rumfahren kann da fallen diese schwarze steine zunächst einmal auf,
das zweite ist dass diese oberflächen geologisch alt sind,
da ist nichts nichts passiert da haben sich keine gebirge aufgetürmt da gibt es keine erosion es gibt wenig wasser es ist keine kulturlandschaft in dem sinne dass der häuser gebaut werden dass das umgepflügt wird keine acker,
das akkumuliert einfach da und liegt tausend jahre lang rum die wahrscheinlichkeit dass seine runterfällt ist genauso groß wie bei jedem vorgarten es bleibt nur liegen,
die zweite wüste die kalte wüste ist die antarktis da es wird organisiert,
gesucht oder logistik natürlich viel schwieriger als die nordafrikanischen füßen das sind alles also offiziell expedition zum beispiel von der nasa und japanischen kollegen belgische kollegen inzwischen chinesische kollegen,
die also dort mit tourette sammeln da gibt es einen großen vorteil,
antarktis ist ja ein kontinent das heißt es ist ja gestein was wirklich eis bedeckt ist und entlang der transatlantischen gebirges kette auf die zufließen die gletscher,
bewegen sich und transportieren material was über die jahrtausende bereits abgesunken war wieder an die oberfläche,
ganz salopp gesprochen weil man könnte sich dahinstellen und warten bis der nächste meteorit von unten wieder hoch transportiert.
So am fließband sozusagen nur ein sehr sehr sehr langsames.
Dauert ein bisschen länger das ist,
aber da wird sehr viel gesammelt und dieses material gelangt übrigens nicht auf den markt also nicht auf den den den,
kauf markt auf den privatmann das wird von den kollegen entweder in zum beispiel in houston washington kuratiert japaner in tokio und natürlich um die größte meteoriten sammlung der welt in tokio das wird klassifiziert bestimmt und wird veröffentlicht,
so dass zu wissenschaftlichen zweck material angefordert werden kann in der sahara ist das anders das material gelangt auf märkte,
zum beispiel in marokko erfurt agadir sakura das sind bekannte mineralien und fossilien märkte und dort werden auch meteoriten verkauft.
Privat konsumer ebay gucken.
Weil leute auch selber unterwegs sind und danach suchen.
Richtig das sind häufig also es fing an in den achtziger jahren mit öl boah ingenieuren von b die waren in libyen,
und brachten sich schwarze steine mit nach hause ohne sofort zu wissen was das ist bisschen mehr man sagt was hast du denn da eigentlich stehen so begann das langsam
und wenn sowas mal anfängt dann fangen natürlich alle an zu suchen patrouillieren die soldaten wie du ihnen und haben das material dann zu den märkten geliefert und und der verkauft,
ich würde nicht sagen dass die wüste leer ist zurzeit aber ich merke schon es wird weniger das hat man schon schon gemerkt ja.
Also antarktis und sahara sozusagen die hotspots gibt ja auch noch andere,
orte wo ich sagen würde da könnt ihr auch noch ausfallen was weiß ich im norden russland also wo man wo man einfach auch so große weitgehend ungewohnte gebiete hat.
Also vegetation ist immer ganz schlecht was gemacht wurde ist planen das ist südwest australien.
Da ist gesucht worden bis es dann mal geregnet hat,
das ist nämlich das berühmte die wüste lebt und man hat dann einfach bewuchs von den kleinen sträuchern es macht es ganz schwierig wurde momentan noch gesucht es ist attacke.
Wollte ich gerade sagen weil das ja sehr trocken.
Sehr trocken da wird gesucht auch gefunden zurzeit was man probiert wurde und nicht so viel gefunden wurde war namibia.
Südafrika im im bereich das sind so so etwas kleinere fundorte chili ist gerade so ein bisschen irgendwo da sind einige kollegen.
Und sammeln.
In der regel wird das wenn das wirklich wissenschaftliche expedition sind wird das in kollaboration mit den mit den jeweiligen geologischen diensten vor ort gemacht damit das eine vernünftige anbindung hat und auch eine legale sache natürlich ist,
und dann werden entweder die funde geteilt oder es wird eine regelung gefunden.
Sind denn alle orte auf der erde im prinzip von der wahrscheinlichkeit getroffen zu werden gleich verteilt oder spielt die erdrotation oder irgendwas da eine rolle.
Ne das ist ja nicht das ist diese tropi immer so schön sagt also gleichmäßig natürlich fahren die meisten das eine fläche hier ins meer.
Es gibt natürlich so ganz seltene funde mal dass jemand davon meeresboden was aufgesammelt hat aber das ist es ist vernachlässigt bei die sind halt weg.
Weil extrem unwahrscheinlich dass man die findet.
Man darf nicht vergessen das fällt auch in salzwasser das auch nicht gesund und dass die erosion ist dann natürlich wahnsinnig hoch.
Okay jetzt brauchen sie ja auch schon die die fälle an also die vorfälle wo man's eben beobachtet hat hat man ja auch gerade vor kurzem dank der immer weiteren verbreitung von,
auto kameras zum beispiel da diese dash cams dazu bei der meteor von chill ja bin in russland ne bei moral genau,
dort schlug ja ein relativ großes objekt in die atmosphäre ein und hat dann entsprechende lauten knall licht blitz et cetera alles kaputte scheiben
man hat so ein bisschen auch gemerkt was da für eine power drin stecken kann wenn die dinger mal ein bisschen größer sind,
das ist wahrscheinlich so ein so ein moment wo dann in ihrer szene die alarmglocken läuten oder dann rutschen doch alle schon die stange runter.
Was was wunderbares natürlich also,
frischer frischer fall das war wie sie schon sagten ja natürlich auch noch spektakulär und dieser meteoriten das ist ja das ist ja immer der fall wenn wenn so ein ein brocken in die erdatmosphäre eintritt dann tut er das mit einer geschwindigkeit von etwa fünfzehn kilometer pro sekunde.
Und dann passieren zwei dinge das erste es wird wahnsinnig heiß er verliert siebzig bis achtzig prozent seiner masse die verdampft,
und in der regel das ist ein stein meteorit gewesen schneller bins der kommt aus dem aus dem all und fliegt auch gegen die atmosphäre fliegt sozusagen gegen die wand,
und häufig ist es so dass der meteoriten zerbricht und was auf der erde unten ankommt sind sogenannte meteoriten schauer das ist also nicht nur ein brocken der runterfällt sondern es sind tausende von brocken,
und so war das dann auch in der regel bleibt eine hauptmatte über die hat man ja geborgen die ist in einem see gefallen der vereist war dann ein schönes loch im im in der eisschicht natürlich oben drüber,
auf dem ganzen weg aus entlang der flugbahn vielen dauernd stücke runter,
dass man eine stücke von murmel größe bis zur fußballgrößen und da setzen natürlich dann sozusagen der run auf diese objekte ein und viele viele händler und sammler sind dann hin geflogen und haben objekte aufgesammelt,
die dann auf dem markt landeten.
Da stellt sich natürlich die frage wie wem gehört denn eigentlich so ein objekt in dem moment eigentlich.
Ja also dann dort hier die die regionalregierung hat keinerlei restriktionen da erhoben beziehungsweise eingeführt das material konnte ausgeführt werden selbst wir haben ein stück,
im naturkundemuseum stehen sehr schön ist es natürlich das wunderbare das ist frisches material das hat die schöne schwarze das ist ideal natürlich
die frage wem gehört das ist nicht so ganz leicht zu zu beantworten viele es gibt wenig gesetzliche regelungen,
zweitausendzwei gab es ein fall in deutschland da ist ein meteor beobachtet worden feuer schweif fotografiert worden von,
und dann ist versucht worden herauszukriegen wo der wohl herunterfiel.
Das ist nicht so ganz leicht solche solche flugbahn zu berechnen aber es waren zwei expedition statt die beide erfolglos blieben,
erfolg hatte dann ein privater meteoriten jäger sage ich mal,
der beim spaziergang dort ein erstes stück davon gefunden hat dass er im hochgebirge der deutsch-österreichischen grenze der meteorit hat den schönen namen neuschwanstein ja genau er hat das schloss nicht getroffen.
Dieses stück wurde auf deutscher seite gefunden im bayerischen staatsforst,
und da setze tatsächlich eine juristische auseinandersetzung zu als seine ja doch auseinandersetzungen ein wem gehört das eigentlich den freistaat bayern empfinde.
Dem könig.
König ludwig genau dem landkreis,
und die die wichtige regelung heißt ist das das ist der bundesland geschichte hat das bundesland ein solches staats- regal,
und das ist eine sache die ich finde die gilt auch bei archäologischen funden himmelsscheibe von nebra zum beispiel irgendeine römische pfund irgendwo in hessen gab es einen riesen streit war ein russisches pferd was gefunden wurde,
ist es also ein schatz,
oder ist es ein herrenloses gegenstand das ist die schöne osten juristische auseinandersetzungen was ist es und in dem moment wo es ein schatz ist hat das land einen anspruch darauf.
Die salomonisches regelung bei diesem fall war dass der freistaat bayern gesagt hat halbe halb.
Und dann war es ihnen zu schade das stück zu sägen durch zu sägen und dann in bayern den finder der stück abgekauft und es liegt heute ein riesenkrater museum in der stadt nördlingen.
Aber wie bestimmt sich denn der preis.
Es gibt einen markt für sowas und es war sechsstellig ja.
Okay also lohnt sich durchaus.
Ja es kann sich lohnen es kann sich lohnen ja also ich weiß zum beispiel das dänemark,
angesetzt was vorschreibt dass meteoriten funde auf den tischen territorium nach kopenhagen ins reichs museum abgeliefert werden müssen.
Gegen finderlohn ich weiß nicht es gab den fall ich weiß aber nicht was er bekommen hat er finde in vielen ländern ist es unklar nicht gesetzlich nicht eindeutig gesetzlich geregelt.
Was wäre denn eine sinnvolle regelung aus ihrer perspektive.
Ja ist immer so ein bisschen abwägen der als wissenschaftler sage ich es gehört ins museum oder das gehört in einem institut oder es muss mindestens wissenschaftlich untersucht werden.
Glaube ich mein wenn's ein anreiz gibt für die leute auch loszugehen und zu suchen ist das ja sozusagen auch ein faktor weil dann kriegt man ja unter umständen auch mehr.
Ist richtig ja das ist natürlich immer immer da genau dazwischen spezies ab,
wir haben eine ganz gute regelung gefunden dadurch dass jetzt über die lange zeit natürlich auch kontakt zu solchen händlern und suchen hat und ich habe die erfahrung gemacht dass wenn es um wissenschaftliche material,
wissenschaftliches material geht sind die sehr sehr sehr kulant also nicht sage ich hätte gerne ein stück für wissenschaftliche untersuchung dann kriege ich das in der regel auch.
Wenn man jetzt mal diesen weg nachvollzieht die so ein objekt macht vielleicht kann man das auch so ein bisschen sozusagen an den parametern die sich dann nochmal neu und so schön abgezeichnet haben festmachen,
also das objekt fliegt unter umständen viele millionen,
bin ich noch länger jahre irgendwie durch die weltgeschichte und ist dann halt aus welchen gründen auch immer dann auf so einer dreieck dorie auf so einem pfad,
der halt dann mit der erde kollidiert jetzt tritt das objekt irgendwann soweit ein und dann vielleicht dann die,
einfach nur die flugbahn oder vielleicht auch noch so ein bisschen die gravitation der erde daran schuld dass es halt irgendwie eingefangen wird jetzt dürfte ja schon mal einen großen unterschied machen wie schräg,
das objekt aufkommt oder ist das eigentlich zu vernachlässigen.
Nicht zu vernachlässigen es gibt einen sogenannten können sich vorstellen wie den den den stein den sie flach übers wasser werfen der taucht eben zunächst nicht ins wasser ein sondern wird an der.
Wasseroberfläche reflektiert und das kann sehr wohl passieren dass ein meteorit so schräg auf die meteroit mit sind noch nicht angekommen auf die atmosphäre trifft und zurück reflektiert wird.
Was auch passiert ist die durch die atmosphäre durch fällt aber gar nicht auf die erde ist ein streifschuss sowas.
Das wurde beobachtet.
Es wurde beobachtet ja gibt's gibt's jetzt foto dokumentiert also das ist das sind natürlich die extremfälle das meiste spielt sich dazwischen ab so dass in der regel in der atmosphäre ein,
ein tritt alles was zum beispiel,
klein ist sternschnuppen das ist ja das was was man häufig mal sieht das material gelang ja nicht in die erdoberfläche sondern verdampft das ist ja das was man da sieht das plasma die heiße luft das ist,
da hatte man den berühmten wunsch frei und das material rieselt kommt nicht auf die erde allerdings muss man sagen die,
die größte menge außerirdische materials was auf die erde fällt staub kongresse kleine einen millimeter.
Also beim staubwischen immer ein bisschen aufpassen das kann gut was außerirdisches dabei sein ja man nennt die mikrometeoriten der kleine ein millimeter man hat die untersucht und wir tun das immer noch,
da gibt's eine ganz lustige geschichte also wenn man wenn man natürlich so aussehen staub untersuchen möchte,
ich möchte den haben dann geht man an orte wo möglichst wenig irdische staub und dann kommen wir zurück wieder zur antarktis habe nämlich tatsächlich eis genommen auf geschmolzen durch,
filtriert durch filter gejagt sozusagen und geguckt was der überblick,
da hat man solche mikrometeoriten kleines außerirdisches material was auch gemacht worden ist man hat die in der stratosphäre selbst gesammelt hat also sehr hochfliegende aufklärungsflugzeug u zwei,
das waren so aufklärung flugzeuge die im kalten krieg von den amerikanern verwendet wurden die fliegen sehr hoch in der stratosphäre und unter die flügel hat man metallplatten montiert die mit so einer art so ein silikonbeutel zogen waren,
sind die durch die stratosphäre geflogen und haben alles aufgesammelt was da oben so rumfliegt also lacksplitter von satelliten vulkanische aschen,
und auch außerirdisches material aber wir reden jetzt von von also sub millimeter großen oder kleinen körnchen.
Quasi mit einem schwamm einfach da lang geflogen.
Das ist so eine art schwamm genau sonst kleber er soll wie so eine wo früher die fliegen dranhängen soll ich mal so sagen sowas sowas in der art hat man aus.
Ja ja motten falle.
Richtig hat man das denn dann gesammelt vor einigen jahren dann auch hier gilt das fällt in der antarktis runter das fällt aber in berlin unter dieser staub vor einigen jahren hat ein norwegischer,
hobby meteoriten jäger angefangen solche mikrometeoriten auf hausdächern zu suchen,
und hat er und hat erfolg gehabt das ist natürlich ein riesen aufwand also stellen sie ist inzwischen selbst hier gemacht wir haben so ein projekt im naturkundemuseum bürger wissenschaften science heißt das sind bei ikea was nicht so leicht war aufs dach,
südkreuz und haben das dach gefegt.
Da haben sie sich bestimmt auch erst mal gewundert als die anfrage reinkam.
Da haben und wollten uns jetzt nicht ein liefern lassen aber das war vielleicht waren sie froh dass das dach mal gefegt wurde aber ist natürlich nicht ganz leicht da oben drauf zu kommen auch aus sicherheitsset gründen natürlich und dann kommt man da runter und hat hundert kilo dreck.
Und dann beginnt der separations-vorschau.
Dieses dach ist wahrscheinlich bis dahin noch nie bewusst irgendwie gereinigt worden und stand dort was nicht i ja der standort den gibt's halt dreißig vierzig jahren oder so.
Ja das ist auf jeden fall nicht gesäubert worden und das ist natürlich das gute wir wollen keine gesäubert dächer für sowas es gab.
Ok aber halt so ein signifikant der sammlung zeitraum sozusagen.
Richtig richtig,
und dann beginnt wie gesagt ein relativ hinten die ist relativ simple prozess das zu separieren das erste was man macht ist man man versucht alles organische wegzukriegen von blättern zweigen und sowas das kann man aufschwimmen
dann wird es abgesiebt das grobes kommt weg weil wir wissen es ist ja halt unter einem millimeter.
Also aufschwimmen erstmal wasser leichte teile gehen nach oben dann ist man das schon mal los okay.
Schon mal einen großen schwung weg das wichtigste an denen es eine magnetische separation denn diese kleinen mikrometeoriten sind alle magnetisch.
Grundsätzlich weil.
Weil sie eisen- freies eisen haben und da kann man durch so eine magnete das ganz gut hinkriegen aber,
die magnete aktion enthält immer noch neunundneunzig prozent irdisches material wenn man wundert sich was aus seinem dach alles rum rum schwebt also rumschwirrt zum beispiel,
kleine metall perlen vom schweißen von schweißarbeiten abgespritzt du vor vom flexen abgespritzt.
Wahrscheinlich noch von den arbeiten die auf dem dach mal stattgefunden.
Wahrscheinlich sogar vom eindecken des daches oder sowas.
Man hätte also eigentlich das dach mal gleich mal zu beginn nochmal fegen.
Ein bisschen zeit braucht man ja bis jetzt runter rieselt aber oder von feuerwerkskörpern,
gibt es material es ist unglaublich was man da an an an irdischen kleinen kügelchen findet und dann beginnt tatsächlich dass das hand hand sortieren und man muss gucken wie sehen sehen sie unterschiedlich aus und.
Aber es ist im wesentlichen so menschlicher müll die man dort findet.
Ja
Und eben ein paar mikrometer also wir waren erfolgreich und das projekt versuchen wir jetzt auch fortzuführen das ist ganz spannend dann mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern dann ein mikroskop zu sitzen und zu gucken ist was was dann gibt's auch schon den ersten meteoriten fund des lebens.
Ja aber jetzt ist natürlich immer noch die frage woran erkennt man ihn okay also generell alles ist magnetisch,
gut nehme ich jetzt mal so zur kenntnis ich weiß nicht warum alles grundsätzlich eisen enthalten muss einfach weil so,
quiter ist weil es einfach überall eisen gibt oder es ist irgendwie eine besondere eigenschaft von methoden ausreden dass dass er immer eisen drin zu finden ist.
Ja das ist eine ganz wichtige eigenschaft ist natürlich nicht alles gibt über die berühmte ausnahme von dieser regel aber die meisten meteoriten.
Ursprünglichen methode haben fein verteiltes eisen-
Wenn man das auf der erde haben möchte sie wissen selbst eisen verrostet deswegen verwenden wir ja eisenerz um um das eisen raus zu gewinnen für für technische zwecke es gibt keine eisen nuggets auf der erde.
Gold-nuggets gibt's platin kupfern all diese edlen metalle keinen sauerstoffverbindungen oder nicht so schnell eingehen gibt's als gediegen wie man so schön sagt eisen nicht wenn man so eine probe auf der erde haben möchte muss man den kern bohren.
Die erde flüssig war alles schwere,
das meiste schwere in den kern gesagt ist das heißt diese eisen- regierung die man in solchen meteoriten findet die gibt's nur im kern der erde das ist unser großer vorteil und es sind ja bruchstücke solche zum beispiel sind pro stücke,
ehemaliger planeten,
planeten mal wie man sie nennt das sind so embryo normale planeten die in der frühphase entstanden kollision wieder zerstört worden sind die hatten ein kern und dieser kern ist jetzt als theorie zum beispiel noch vorhanden,
also diese magnet separation um dir auf die frage nochmal zurückzukommen ist der ist der der auf der finale schritt wo man große mengen separieren kann und dann geht's an das
das hand picken das aussortieren unter dem mikroskop und woran erkennt man das jetzt der trick ist wenn ich das richtig,
sehe auf diesem reflektieren etwas anders also die schweißperlen schweißperlen sind viel glänzender.
Als mikrometer diesen stumpfer,
damit kriegt man das hin was man dann tatsächlich noch machen muss um das zu verifizieren ist man muss an elektronenmikroskop gehen und dort eine zumindest grobe chemische analyse hin produzieren und um sicher zu sein dass es tatsächlich ausreiche ist.
Das heißt so richtig automatisieren lässt sich dieser vorgang nicht mit laser oder so.
Das ist am ende dann harte hand das ist man sitzt dann da und guckt stundenlang das mikroskop.
Was ist denn so die ausbeute von so einem ikea dach.
Ikea war relativ erfolgreich also bestimmt hundert.
Hundert einzelne kleine objekte in der größenordnung von.
Kügelchen genau kleiner millimetern null komma drei millimeter dreihundert kilometer sind das ja.
Okay aber das ist dann für sie schon eine gute ausbeute und was kann man denn da sozusagen herauslesen aus dieser sammlung.
Also die idee sich mit solchen kosmischen staub zu beschäftigen ist folgende,
sie haben von kometen schon erwähnt committen sind ja die körper mit dem schweif von außen außeren sonnensystem ins innere sonnensystem reinkommen aufheizen schweif entwickeln zwei schweifen plasma schweifen staub schweif und dieser staub,
ist vermutlich die haupt qualle dessen glaube ich auf die erde rieselt das heißt die idee ist.
Die frage dahinter können wir was über kometen lernen aus diesem staub.
Also die die kometen schweife die sozusagen in unserer umgebung für kurze zeit zu sehen sind,
liefern mehr material als alle anderen kleinen zerplatzte meteoriten die so auf der oberfläche aufschlagen und wo der staub durch die explosion des der aufheizung hergestellt wird,
ok
Und es gibt ja immer wieder diesen effekt der leoniden gemini schauer nirgendwo also was weiß ich tausend sternschnuppen sichtbar sind in einer stunde oder sowas das ist genau der fall dass die erde durch,
so ein schweif eines kometen durchrotieren.
Und in diesem zeitraum wahnsinnig viel von diesem staub aufsammelt das meiste verglüht und das sind die berühmten sternschnuppen aber es fehlt eben auch was auf der erde.
Wie lange ist das jetzt her mit dem ikea dach letztes jahr und haben sie schon im kalender markiert in zehn jahren gehen wir dann nochmal vorbei machen die aktion nochmal und dann wissen wir auch was so durchschnittlich da so drauf hält.
Das ist genau die idee wir wollen perspektivisch so mikrometeoriten fallen installieren um um den schluss rauszubringen also wieviel kommt eigentlich weil das ist das was man in antarktis nicht so systematisch gemacht hat,
man könnte das natürlich tun wir haben jetzt auch angefangen dass man bock kern,
abläuft und guckt wie alt ist eigentlich die eisschicht hat sich dieser hat sich dieser fluss verändert über die jahrtausende da braucht man eine gewisse statistik zehn jahre reichen mal gucken,
aber wir sind vorher noch auf anderen dächern also wir haben schon vor wenn das wetter ist wieder erlaubt wieder hochzugehen es sollte nicht regnen und es sollte auch nicht so knallheiß sein wie letzten sommer waren weil dann,
dann wird es auch sehr unangenehm.
Ok aber so richtig mit schwerer arbeit draußen verbunden.
Das ist so richtig da macht man sich auch dreckig ja.
Ok und spricht ja nicht mehr so dem stereotyp dessen tour wissenschaftlers der versichert museum einschließt ich werde euch mal kurz den,
fahrt aufnehmen den ich vorhin begonnen hatte was passiert jetzt mit diesem objekt also das objekt nähert sich der erde und dann hatten wir so fall eins okay kann sein dass es zu flach ist und wie so ein kleines steinchen auf dem see wird es wieder
ins all geschossen ist dann weg bleibt vielleicht ein klein bisschen was übrig aber im wesentlichen ist das ding aus den augen aus dem sinn,
ab welchem winkel geht's dann los also bis man nicht so genau.
Schwer zu sagen.
Ja aber irgendwann reicht's sozusagen dass eben nicht reflektiert wird sondern das ding tritt ein können sie jetzt sozusagen so meteoriten schon ansehen wie schräg der gekommen ist weil,
mehr oder weniger verglüht da mehr wenn das ding schräg eintaucht oder ist es eher egal.
Also das ist glaube ich gespielt keine so große rolle was man allerdings nachher also wer taucht ein mit sehr heiß sehr heiß jetzt weit über zweitausend grad erzeugen plasma das material verdampft irgendwann.
Dass der sternschnuppen moment.
Dass der sternschnuppen moment richtig und wenn material überbleibt dann kriegt das reststück eine schwarze schmelzkäse außen die sehr sehr sehr dünn,
dünner als ein millimeter und im inneren also unter der schmelz kruste ist dieser stein forscht nicht unverändert,
also nicht so dass dieses eintreten der mann chemie verändert oder oder die die die mineral logie verändert oder irgendetwas sondern der stein ist unterhalb der schmelz größte völlig unversehrt.
Dann gibt es den punkt an dem er soweit abgebremst ist dass er nur noch mit fallgeschwindigkeit runterfällt.
Also er kommt nicht mit kosmische geschwindigkeit unten an dafür müssen dafür brauchen wir riesen ob denn die atmosphäre egal ist und kilometer objekte oder so was die wollen wir nicht so unbedingt haben richtig.
Wie gesagt das fallgeschwindigkeit der fällt runter ist in der regel auch nicht mehr unbedingt warm wenn er unten ankommt,
was man bei manchen meteoriten sieht das lässt vielleicht was über sie meinten ist die sind orientiert wenn sie sich vorstellen die schmelzen größte ist ja schmelze und wenn die durch die luft fliegt kann die formen annehmen,
flug form also so riefen oder man könnte man man sieht wie er in welche richtung er geflogen ist das kann man bei einigen an einigen objekten sehr schön sehen wie gesagt man nennt sie dann orientierte die sind auch einfach schön wenn man hier auf dem auf dem tisch hat,
und das gibt dann so ein bisschen die idee darüber wenn der ist jetzt von rechts gekommen sage ich mal oder jetzt in diese richtung geflogen.
Aber diese schmelz größe bildet die sich erst nachdem das objekt unter umständen auseinandergebrochen ist.
Wenn ein meteoriten schauer auf die erde feld hat jeder jedes stück.
Eine spät größe ok,
man könnte ja auch meinen so okay trifft auf fängt schon mal an zu schmelzen aber dann wird es zu heiß dann bricht's erst auseinander und dann ist keine schmerzen mehr da dem ist nicht so ist einfach lang genug heiß genug das alles überall etwas hat okay.
Also die richtigen frischen funde von solchen meteoriten schauen jedes einzelne stück gekostet wie man.
Und was macht ihr so so sicher dass es da drunter unverändert ist meine was man ja nicht wie es vorher war.
Man sieht das sehr gut also wenn sie sich jetzt ein stück aufschneiden und gucken sich das dem mikroskop an da gibt es eine klare trennung zwischen der der kruste und dem inneren natürlich gibt's einen kleinen übergangsbereich aber wir reden hier maximalen millimeter und da drunter ist der stein.
Unversehrt.
Unversehrt als wenn nichts mit ihm passiert wäre genau fehler bildstöcke übrigens auch alle schwunde schöne schwarze größte.
Ja
Was passiert dann also wenn so ein objekt jetzt gefunden wird also bleiben wir doch mal bei cäcilia binz wie groß ist so ihr stück.
Verfasst groß ja das ist ein schönes stück ja ja das ist ein schönes stück.
Faust groß bist schon gut oder da freut man sich schon drüber so dann wird das irgendwie eingetütet wie haben sie denn das wort bekommen also war das so ein geschenk oder hat man einfach mal gefragt ihr habt doch genug gib doch mal eins aha.
Käuflich erworben eine ganz wenigen schritte die wir tatsächlich angekauft haben.
Darf man den preis sagen.
Ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht mehr ganz auswendig aber ich glaube wir haben dreitausend euro für das stück bezahlt.
Ok also mehr so handling gebühr eigentlich als wirklich wert.
Ja das ist noch überschaubar ja.
Ja dann kommt das ding irgendwie per post oder wie.
In diesem fall diesen verlief das über über eine kontaktperson die hier in deutschland bei uns selbst da gesammelt hat.
Ok das heißt er fährt an einer hin und dann wird das wie in so einem schreien irgendwie nach berlin getragen.
Aber es ist aber wirklich völlig unterschiedlich ich kriege viele viele meteoriten auch zur bestimmung dann einfach zugeschickt,
kommt ein päckchen oder sowas ganz regulär und manchmal hat man dann spaß am zoll weil nicht nicht nicht draufsteht was was drin ist und dann verbringt man dann ein paar stunden.
Versucht.
Und versucht zu erklären was daran was dieser schwarze stein soll und was vor allen dingen was er wert das ist ja für den soll immer ganz ganz wichtig weil danach richtet sich das natürlich und.
Müssen sie auch zoll zahlen für meteoriten.
In der regel nicht das sind ja das hängt auch davon ab,
wofür ist das material wenn es zu wissenschaftlichen zwecken ist nicht häufig sind sie auch teilweise rückführung in die sammlung wir hatten ich hatte tatsächlich mal in einen fall da hatte ich ein ein meteorit verliehen an kolleginnen vereinten staaten.
Dass die kollegin fertig war mit ihren untersuchung hat sie das stück zurück geschickt und hat drauf geschrieben wer zweitausendfünfhundert dollar das war keine gute idee.
Na gut da fragt man sich dann gleich wie die umsatzsteuer regelung im all ist.
Ja
So jetzt kommt das ding an und dann stehen wahrscheinlich alle ganz aufgeregt ums päckchen herum.
Und dann was machst du jetzt kommt's erstmal ins regal oder legt man das denn gleich und das irgendwie ein mikroskop oder schießt man irgendwas.
Wenn man bei uns bleiben dass das stück haben wir tatsächlich für führungen und für ausstellungen erworben dahaben wir wissenschaftlich nicht dran gearbeitet weil er wissenschaftlich schon bearbeitet wurde,
das ist ja das was normalerweise passiert ist mit tourette werden klassifiziert das ist jetzt was wie so eine zoologischer oder biologische taxi also was ist das eigentlich ist ein steinsee oder es ist reines eisen ist es eine mischung da gibt es verschiedenste klassen,
wissenschaftlich definierte klassen wichtig ist das vor allen dingen natürlich für uns um zu sehen ist etwas spannendes spektakuläres kann ich was daraus lernen für die händler ist es wichtig ganz sehr kommerziell danach richtet sich einfach der wert von dem stück ist es was seltenes,
logisch wird teurer als was was man häufig findet vom typ her ist dann sehr schnell bestimmt worden war ja auch genug material da,
und dann wird das normalerweise nicht für jedes einzelne stück aus dem gleichen fall wiederholt.
Weil man letztlich immer wieder auf dasselbe ergebnis kommen würde.
Richtig man nimmt also ein typ stück sägt das auf macht ein duft dünnen schnitt geht damit ans mikroskop macht chemie und was auch immer und,
solche frischen fälle haben noch ein paar andere positive eigenschaften der wissenschaftler lieben diese frische stücke weil sie eben nicht auf der erde verändert wurden,
da hat's nicht tausend jahre lang drauf geregnet und ich kann immer noch was ursprüngliches lernen das ist vor allen dingen wichtig für organische substanzen in der,
dass da tausend jahre lang rumliegt finde ich organic aber das ist dann nicht unbedingt die ausländische sondern es hat vielleicht eine irdische kontamination das ist bei frischen fällen natürlich was anderes und das stück kommt grade aus dem all da ist wenig mit passiert auf der erde also sehr interessant,
was man auch noch lernen kann ist bei solchen funden es vorhin schon angedeutet das ding fliegt millionen jahre durchs all und in dieser zeit,
kriegt das den vollen sonnenwind ab.
Hat ja keine atmosphäre drumherum die erde fällt ein sehr lustiger weise das meiste davon vom leibe und dann passiert an reaktionen zwischen dem gestein und diesem sonnenwind,
entstehen radioaktive elemente,
die entstehen während des fluges durchs all fällt der stein auf die auf die erde entstehen keine neuen mehr und die die produziert werden zerfallen.
Was man machen kann also man kann sozusagen darüber ein ein flug alter wie lange war das überhaupt das stück im all wie lange ist das bestrahlt worden,
und bei stücken die man findet in der wüste kann man übrigens so auch noch ein solches irdisches alter bestimmen wenn man das möchte wie lange liegt es da eigentlich.
Das ist relativ aufwendig aber es ist erstaunlich also es kommen also das loch der älteste welt höchste irdische alter für ein antarktischen lack bei einer million jahre,
liegt ja auf der erde bevor aufgesammelt wurde.
Auf offen rum sozusagen eine millionen jahre hat kein interessiert.
Das ist aber das ist genau also das ist nett aber jetzt das susanne ist das ende der fahnenstange doch schon erstaunlich.
Und in der sahara.
Kann ich ihnen gar nicht so genau sagen paar tausend ist so dass das normale vermutlich wie gesagt die untersuchung ist sehr aufwendig.
Und das jüngste vielleicht noch so 'ne extrem was mama zur kenntnis genommen hat ja.
Frischer fall natürlich ne,
es gab eine marokko vor ein paar jahren tisch sind heißt der mars meteorit der spackt spektakulär natürlich wahnsinnig interessant wissenschaftlichen frischer maß und ist auch gut untersucht inzwischen gab es viel material.
Frischer maß.
Okay jetzt war das mit dem chilli ein schlechtes beispiel aber jetzt sagen wir nochmal es gibt jetzt einen noch nicht bestimmten und es fällt ihnen jetzt sozusagen zu diese bestimmung vorzunehmen
wie findet das dann statt also sägt man ihn dann erstmal auf oder dass man erstmal in ruhe,
macht erstmal ohne irgendeine modifikation alles erdenkliche welche maßnahmen ergreift man denn jetzt konkret.
Die bestimmung eines meteoriten läuft.
Immer über anschneiden also bisherigen ein stück auf und zwar nicht mittig sondern irgendwo in erkannte,
erzeugen also eine dünne so eine scheibe und von von dieser dünnen scheibe wird dann regelmäßig werden wir gestein zu dünn schliffe hergestellt,
dieses objekt muss man sich so vorstellen wird auf ein objekt kläger träger gekittet geklebt objektträger wie sie den kennen von blutstropfen oder wassertropfen draufgeklebt dann wird nochmal abgesägt ganz dünn.
Der restliche vom gestein wird fein geschliffen und poliert,
dicke beträgt dann etwa noch so dreißig mikrometer ein millimeter tausend mikrometer also sehr dünn und.
Wenn es ein meteorit ist können sie denn da durch gucken sie können mit dem optischen mikroskop beim licht mikroskop können sie den mikros kopieren.
Geübten leute die sich damit auskennen können dann sagen was es ist in der regel man sieht also die mineralien man sieht wie die verwachsen sind miteinander hat auch keine chemischen informationen aber man hat eine information über
die bestandteile und über die textur bei das gefüge.
Dann geht man in der tat in der regel ans elektronenmikroskop oder an eine elektronische mikro sonde und bestimmt die chemische zusammensetzung der mineralien.
Meistens reicht das dann aus um zu sagen was für eine klasse was für ein typ ist es.
Ausnahmen da muss man ein bisschen ein bisschen weitergehen bestimmte isotov open untersuchung machen um zu gucken wo landet man aber das ist so dass das das klassische prozedere also ich kriege so im im jahr hundertfünfzig meter ritter auf meinem tisch die ich so behandelt.
Hundertfünfzig ok also kannst du was zu tun jede woche.
Es kommt einiges und dazu kommen natürlich auch noch viele viele die keine sind das passiert auch,
in der regel jetzt aber nicht mehr von von händlern die wissen inzwischen auch man trefferquote von fünfundneunzig prozent kann mal sein dass ein irdischer basalt dabei ist der auch schwarz ist und in der wüste lag das passiert aber das ist eher die ausnahme zwischen die wissen was sie tun.
Aber schwarz sind die immer.
Nein die sind nicht immer schwarz die frischen sind schwarz was in der sahara zum beispiel passiert ist viele sahara meteoriten haben keine kruste mehr die sind nämlich tausend jahre gesandstrahlt worden weil das immer kontinuierlich der wüstensand drüber gebet worden und dann ist die kruste.
Abrasiert man hat manchmal so effekte da man man nennt die windkante auch da kommt bevorzugte windrichtung westen das heißt die westliche seite des steins hat er hat keine größte mehr.
Die windabgewandten seite hat noch.
Das heißt schwarz ist eigentlich nur die außenhaut die schmelz haut die ist schwarz weil sie eben geschmolzen ist aber da drunter findet man dann alles mögliche so wie wir das auch von der erde kennen oder okay.
Also es gibt natürlich mit drin die bleiben darunter auch schwarz kohlenstoff reiche meteoriten jetzt gerade die aktuellen mission hayabusa zwei siris rex fliegen jetzt zu solchen kohlenstoff reichen asteroiden diesen schwarz die auch in diesen auch im im im im teleskop schwarz,
aufgrund des hohen anteil an kohlenstoff die bleiben da drunter schwarze schmerzgrenze schwarze innere das ist kaum einen unterschied in der schwärze sozusagen,
aber sonst sehen sie alle möglichen arten von gestein nehmen.
Interessant dass sie das ansprechende vor zwei sendungen habe ich mich ja mit rami hoch vom drk unterhalten über genau diese zwei mission und da sprach mir sozusagen auch schon auf so die
wissenschaftliche nähe zur meteoriten forschung da gab es auch eine konkrete kooperation mit ihnen oder
dr kam irgendwann mal angelaufen.
Ja das ist ja schön bei zwei gibt es ja schon daten also das ist ja eine sample return mission das heißt es wird material,
zurückgebracht auf die erde aber von dem länder gibt es schon eine ganze reihe von daten die auf der oberfläche des asteroiden gewonnen wurden,
es waren kollegen vom da die hatten kamera daten also ganz salopp gesagt fotos in verschiedenen wellenlängen und haben versucht und haben geschaut ob es in unserer meteoriten sammlung analog material gibt also gibt es meteoriten die das gleiche zeigen,
kann man sagen bestimmte methode klasse ist am nächsten dran an dem was auf viagogo gesehen wurde,
das wird häufig bei uns gemacht wir haben also auch viele spektrums komiker infrarotspektroskopie gekommen um die die proben die wir haben zu vergleichen mit spektren die während mission während eine mission aufgenommen wurden.
Was kann man denn aus diesen spektren herauslesen.
Man kann zum beispiel rauslesen wie viel wasser die haben ob die wasser haben,
das war eine der großen überraschungen von hayabusa zwei des steins scheint erstaunlich trocken zu sein während die kohlenstoff reichen meteorit in unseren sammlungen nicht so trocken sind,
am wasser bis zu zehn prozent.
Das war eine überraschung wie das wasser daraus wenn es das gleiche material ist eigentlich nur durch erwärmen kann es sein dass in der frühphase da so viele radioaktive energie noch da war dass sie es leicht warm wurde macht sich neunzig grad dass das wasser.
Verloren gegangen ist gibt es solche methoden in unseren sammlungen dann passieren auch ganz interessante sachen da hat man vor zehn jahren mal fünf meter heute beschrieben die solche signaturen zeigen hatte dann sozusagen vergessen,
die community gar nicht wahrgenommen weil sie in anführungsstrichen kein bezug hatten und jetzt plötzlich haben sie einen und dann passiert natürlich was dass die leute anfangen an den stücken wieder zu arbeiten.
Das heißt mit den daten des ddr konnten sie so viel anfangen um zu sagen ja sowas hatten wir schon mal vor zehn jahren was lag das schon digital vor.
Das ist das haben wir gemacht das sind japanische daten das sind das sind vom yamato eisfeld und arktis gesammelte meteoriten die daten gibt artikel,
geschrieben hast du geschrieben ist mal nachgucken was wann genau alles publiziert hatte nur nicht so eine relevanz wie sie jetzt durch die beobachtung von von von hayabusa.
Aber sowas muss man auch erst mal finden also.
Und das ist auch nicht ganz klar also das ist wie wie ist das passiert wir sind die erwärmt worden.
Wie ist das wasser da raus gegangen aber wie gesagt jetzt gibt es eine ganze reihe von forschergruppen die natürlich an an dem material arbeiten und sind sehr gespannt was was der länder tatsächlich mitbringen.
Aber konnten sie denn die lernen irgendwas also war denn dann irgendwas zu finden also konnten sie mit den informationen die es ddr jetzt aus diesem kamera daten hat irgendwie irgendein rückschluss auf irgendein ein sample aus ihrer sammlung auch herstellen.
Ja also wir sind zumindest nah ran gekommen wir sind nicht identisch die spektrum sind nicht identisch aber so dass ich sage mal das ursprüngliche material was wir haben am wenigsten verändert material kommt am nächsten,
an die spektren die da gesammelt wurden ran,
es sind ja auch wir sind ja auch fotos das ist ja ganz spannend die dann gemacht worden sind von einer ganz normalen ganz normalen von optischen kamera
unter verschiedenen belichtungszeiten bedingungen es gibt einen tag und nacht auf dem auf dem asteroiden und benachbarte haben die weiter fotografiert dann haben wir aber künstlich beleuchtet mit idioten,
und da hat man andere wellenlänge als beim tageslicht zum beispiel,
und diese verschiedene spektren sind aufgenommen worden an den meteoriten und ich muss sagen ja es gibt eine eine typen klasse die am nächsten rankommt.
Das nächste spannende ist ja zu fragen die daten von joghurt zeigen dass er sehr porösen material ist sehr.
Bröckelig ist sage ich mal in anführungsstrichen schätze ich mal die frage würde eigentlich so ein material den eintritt in die erdatmosphäre überleben,
also kunden besonders daran überhaupt bekommen oder nicht die gleiche frage gilt für bestimmte maß gesteine.
Weil alles verglühen würde oder war so klein ist dass man es einfach nicht finden.
Richtig also komplett zerbrechen wurde nicht das ist ja immer die mechanik,
des aufpralls und dann haben wir die temperatur also es kann gut mit sicherheit so dass man das material gibt was was diesen diese beanspruchung dieser beanspruchung nicht nicht standhält,
wir wissen dass zum beispiel vom mars wenn ich das nochmal ergänzen darf wir wissen dass es auf dem mars salze gibt also gibt's zum beispiel entweder gloria,
also wenn sie stück gibst durch die erdatmosphäre schicken mit fünfzehn kilometern pro sekunde glaube ich nicht dass das hier landet,
also wenn man sich dermaßen meteoriten anguckt das ist ja immer erstaunlich dass wir das alles vulkanische gestein ist also bei salte in anführungsstrichen oder ähnliche mathematische gestalten muss mal so
ganze mythologien von dem wir wissen dass sie auf dem mars existieren hat ist nicht abgebildet in den in den sammlung von maß-mittwoch.
Aber nicht weil's nicht kommt sondern weil es einfach nicht den weg auf den boden schafft.
Wunderbar von der wahrscheinlichkeit und muss das auch kommen ist ein bisschen spekulativ jetzt aber es ist eben eine eine sehr naheliegende erklärung.
Sie haben gesagt sie sollen sich das an und dann ordnen sie das in klassen und typen ein wieviele unterschiedliche klassen werden dann so unterschieden also auf was was für daten faktoren bezieht sich so eine kategorisierung.
Also die die erste grob kategorisierung ist es gibt steinmetz- heute es gibt eisen mit leute,
und es gibt steineichen mit leute das ist die ganz grobe obendrüber stehende klassifikation wo sich die steinmetze anguckt dann gibt es welche die sind seit der entstehung unseres sonnensystems unverändert,
ist nichts passiert,
also alle die prozesse die sie von der erde kennen verbitterung wasser gebirge bildung druck temperatur haben die nicht gesehen,
das sind sogenannte kosmische sedimente nennen wir die das haben sich die ersten bestandteile unseres sonnensystems sie vor viereinhalb milliarden jahren entstanden sind die ersten festen körper ähnlich wie bei einer voll maus,
durch anziehungskraft zusammen geballt das war's.
Diese brunnen diese kleinen ersten objekte zwei mineralputz fasen zwei phasen das ist das älteste material diesen diese einzelnen älter als der stein,
der stand ist ja sozusagen durch zum zusammenballen dieser einzelnen objekte entstanden.
Das ist sozusagen wirklich das material.
Das sind diese berühmten vier komma fünf sechs milliarden jahre die immer liest das ist das erste feste material unseres landes dem dienst sind in diesem meteoriten enthalten erhalten.
Ersten festen proben unseres sonnensystems die wir überhaupt haben wo wir sagen können so und jetzt haben wir das davor ist gastronomie astrophysik hier ist aber jetzt plötzlich ein stein oder mineral.
Im prinzip ist das so die geburt der geologie älter wird es nicht.
Könnte man fast sagen ja also diese klasse gibt es deshalb sehr ursprünglichen.
Woher weiß man denn dass das so alt ist.
Das ist über relative zerfallen rein datiert worden.
Also es lässt sich auch bei so einem material immer noch anwenden diese methode.
Genug drin ist und das ist ja das schöne dass also der fortschritt der technologie das ist ja immer so ein bisschen hin und her wissenschaftler stellen fragen und sagen sagen den ingenieuren jetzt bei uns mal bitte ein gerät dass das auch messen kann und das ist in den letzten jahren natürlich.
Exponentiell gestiegen die möglichkeiten es geht um minimierung von fehlern wenn ich wenn ich es prozesse auf aufspalten möchte wer hat sich jetzt das eine mineral gebildet wie viel später hat sie denn das andere.
Wenn das jetzt aber nur zwei millionen jahre später sind dann darf der fehler in der messung die vier millionen jahre sein und also diese präzision und die die das hat den letzten jahren massiv zugenommen ein gutes beispiel ist,
es gibt ja meteoriten enthalten auch material das nicht aus unserem sonnensystem kommt.
Extra solaris material was in unser sonnensystem zum beispiel durch sternenecke explosion durch supernova hinein geschossen wurde man nennt diese dinger interstellaren körner das sind.
Mikrometer große mineralien die hat man zum ersten mal identifiziert indem man mit toilette aufgelöst hat.
Also ein steinmetz- und jetzt bestellen sie alle möglichen grausamen säuren vor diese so kennen ja von königs wasser überfluss eure und am ende blieb was über,
und das waren diese extra preise oder solaren körner diamanten silizium-karbit-
mitreden had stoffe was auch diesen diesen lösungsprozess natürlich überlebt und die hatten zum beispiel sauerstoff oder kohlenstoff isar open die sowas von außer die nicht solar sind,
nicht in unserem sonnensystem.
Weil man die noch nicht gesehen hat oder weil man weiß dass sie sich so bei uns gar nicht bilden können.
Wenn man weiß dass sie sich in bestimmten sternen bilden oder bei einer supernova entstehen.
Bestimmten arten von sternen die unserer stern eben nicht ist ok.
Gastronomen sagten das ist schön dass sie die diamanten ihr seht dass ihr diese silizium-karbit- aber wenn wir in diesem salarium medium gucken in die galaxie gucken dann sehen wir da gibt es silikat.
Mineralöl ich sage die namen mal uli wien griechischen als grünes und grünes mineral seen die sehen wir da oben warum findet ihr die nicht ganz einfach die lösen wir auf.
Das war ja der nachteil dieser technik.
Die überleben das nicht ja.
Sie überleben das nicht und inzwischen ist man aber so weit in ein paar jahren dass man insitut in dem gestein in so einem durchschnitt den ich vorhin erwähnte mit geräten diese diese verhältnisse messen kann und jetzt hat man auch die interstellaren silikat,
es ist immer so ein bisschen so ein so ein hin und her das ist man findet die hauptsächlich in solchen primitiven sage ich mal in solchen ursprünglichen meteoriten,
aber auf asteroiden gab es auf zwei prozesse die diese ursprüngliche materialien verändert haben das eine ist nämlich in der tat wasser es gab in der frühphase des sonnensystems flüssiges wasser.
Und dieses flüssige wasser hat die mineralien verändert hat sie verwittert.
Also es gab das flüssige wasser auf auf körpern okay weil die nagel noch an der erde an der sonne waren und dann eben auch diese temperatur bedingungen hatten wie wir das eben jetzt von der erde her kennen und dann wird's da auch flüssiges wasser gegeben haben.
Und das hat was mit den stein gemacht,
wenn sie jetzt jeden stein nehmen was halten im schmeißen den fluss kommt nach zweihundert jahren wieder dann ist der verwittert die mineralien entstehen nennt man ton mineral also wenn's ein klumpen ton in die hand nehmen und drücken den kommt mir ein bisschen wasser raus das ist in diesen schichten eingebaut.
So was gibt's auch in methoden also das ist nicht so nicht auf der erde passiert also nicht verwechseln mit der irdischen verwitterung sondern es ist mutter körperverletzung,
und das zweite was passiert ist wir haben häufiger jetzt schon über einen relativen zerfall gesprochen in der frühphase unseres sonnensystems gab es ein paar elemente die heute gar nicht mehr als radioaktive isotov existieren zwischen aluminium radioaktives aluminium,
sechsundzwanzig gibt's nicht mehr komplett zerfallen hat aber in der frühphase sonnensystems massiv zu der zu der wärme auf den körper beigetragen,
dazu kam einschläge natürlich aber vor dieser innere wärme kommt durch den zerfall von radioaktiven isotov,
wenn wir jetzt eine methode nimmt und erhitzt den dann kann erstmal sagen sag mal so ab neunhundert grad wird es spannend weil dann beginnt die ersten phasen zu schmelzen.
Das metall zum beispiel fängt an zu schmelzen und dann sitzt ein prozess ein den wir auf der erde erkennen beziehungsweise den stattgefunden hat der gelogen nennt das differenziert i o n.
Metall das schwere sagt nach innen.
Die dinge trennen sich.
Trennen sich genau und die hier auf der erde die haben den kern wir haben den mantel der flüssig ist wir haben die kruste auf der warum laufen
das nennt man einen differenzierten körper nennt der geologie das das ist ein prozess und dazwischen gibt's alle möglichen schritte ich kann ja auch vierhundert grad erhöhen,
da passiert noch nicht so viel da lernen sie vielleicht die mineralöle fang an zu wachsen oder sowas und all diese schritte sind dokumentiert in den meteoriten.
Ausgelöst durch das radioaktive aluminium.
Richtig was passiert wenn der körper je größer der körper ist der mutter körper ich rede von asteroiden zum beispiel desto mehr wärme keine produzieren,
die größten asteroiden unseres sonnensystems wester zum beispiel ein paar hundert kilometer achthundert kilometer sowas im durchmesser,
der war vermutlich in der lage oder war in der lage der ist differenziert wir hatten kern und hat eine silikat fülle und steine von westphal sind basalt vulkanische gesteine die haben da nichts mehr mit diesem ursprünglichen.
Kohlenstoff reichen mit hütten zu tun diesen völlig verändert wir haben auch kein metall mehr das ist ja im kern von beste.
Vor einigen jahren die mission dorn.
Ich wollte gerade fragen aus welcher mission in diese information kommt.
Das ist dorn gewesen und bester sind die beiden größten asteroiden unseres sonnensystems wir sind ja schuld daran dass pluto kein planet mehr ist.
Unter anderem.
Das hätten wir jetzt zur zeit und genau das hat man ein paar mehr jetzt ne und die dornbirn nasa mission die diese beiden großen asteroiden besucht hat,
und wir haben material von denen es gibt meteoriten von diesen differenzierten körpern.
Jetzt um vielleicht mal kurz ein bisschen zurück zu spulen wir waren ja bei dieser klassifizierung und sie sprachen davon okay man unterscheidet erstmal grob steinen eisen und
steigeisen mitarbeiten und ich glaube auf diesen ganzen pfad der des materials immer jetzt gekommen,
in der betrachtung der stein meteoriten also das ist sozusagen das älteste was man bekommen kann und,
es gibt einerseits den blick frei auf die quasi den uhr nebel des sonnensystems also das woraus sich alles herausgebildet hat die sonne alle planeten,
moni etcetera p p alles was so rumschwirrt plus dinge die von woanders her kam es kann ja sagen,
da ist ja noch nicht gab kam mir alles eigentlich von woanders her also wo kann man denn da noch diese unterscheidung machen ich meine auch gold zum beispiel,
kann ja nicht,
von hier gekommen sein weil unsere sonne nicht groß genug ist um gold zu erzeugen also wo kann man denn dann diese linie überhaupt ziehen mit das ist jetzt ein präziser klarer körper und das ist irgendwie das gehört zu uns.
Das ist ja insofern es wäre ja auch gold sozusagen solar.
Also richtig also alle elemente größer als eisen schwerer als eisen sind sind in einem normalen stern sozusagen nichts
zu produzieren das muss über neue neutron anfangen prozesse laufen in der regel durch supernova explosion oder ähnliche ähnliche konstrukte man unterscheidet es eigentlich alles material was durch kondensationskerne des solaren nebels also das ist an der uhr,
brühe unseres sonnensystems entstanden ist das ist unsere was als festes material reingeschossen wurde das sind diese
prasolov waren körner die die sozusagen nichts mit uns zusammen ja vollig recht das ist ja da sozusagen das sind das sind ja die die prozesse die sternen prozesse die das durchlaufen
man bildet ein sonnensystem irgendwann ist der stern tot oder explodiert und es wird wieder reingemischt in den nächsten sternen entstehungsprozess das ist natürlich der der kreislauf für den es.
Wir kommen ja auch nicht aus dem nichts also sozusagen wir wären nicht vorher schon eine unbekannte zahl von anderen sternen mal explodiert dann gäbe es halt uns in der zusammensetzung so wie wir halt jetzt nicht,
du bist die erde in dieser zusammensetzung so nicht.
Ja völlig richtig also wie gesagt die grenze wird da gezogen.
Was wir jetzt mit den anderen klassen mit den eisen meteoriten und stein eisen warum nennt man das so was was ist da der unterschied die bestehenden nur oder im wesentlichen aus eisen oder haben überhaupt eisen.
Also eisenbart heute wenn sie den jetzt auf dem tisch hier haben würde es einfach ein brocken eisen richtig gediegenes eisen chemisch sind die meisten von diesen eisen meteoriten eine mischung aus eisen und mittel.
Und haben so im durchschnitt sieben prozent niklas und typischer wert,
wenn man sich das ein bisschen genauer anguckt dann ist man ganz erstaunt weil das war früher flüssig so ähnlich wie der ein teil des erdkabel flüssig ist und wenn man dieses jetzt abkühlt so 'ne eisen nickel legierung dann entstehen zwei,
verbindungen dass ein bisschen kristalle.
Es ist wenn du ein eisen sie denkt man so eine homogene masse nein das ist kristallin es entsteht eine phase die hat viel nickel.
Deshalb eine phase die hat wenig nickel,
die begriffe hören wollt hat mehr nickel als das sind diese beiden eisen nickel-titan-legierung die trennen sich voneinander die entmischen nennt man das während des abkühlen,
und sie sind kristalle graphisch orientiert miteinander verwachsen stimmen orientierung,
es hat ein österreichischer physiker namens alois graf von bittmann städten sichtbar gemacht das erste mal er hat nämlich so ein eisen metroid genommen hat die fläche an poliert und hat sie mit salpeter säure geätzt.
Jetzt hat man den großen vorteil dass die eisen den nickel reiche und die arme substanz unterschiedlich gegenüber der salpeter säure reagieren man legt die kristall flächen,
frei man sieht es man sieht dass es nur ein wittmann städtchen figuren sind so streifenmuster immer nur in eisen meteoriten findet.
Die abkühlung raten um solche lamellen solche verbindungen zu erzeugen sind viel zu hoch.
Als dass man sie im labor reproduzieren könnte man kann kein sozusagen fälschen also ein grad pro eine million jahre,
das ist dann für die labor nummer ein bisschen ein bisschen zu viel das sind die bittmann städtchen figuren bei eisen meteoriten,
also wir haben einen großen vorteil die haben eine höhere festigkeit als steinmetz dritte das heißt die die größten noch existierenden meteoriten auf der erde sind eisen.
Die zerbrechen einfach viel weniger schnell beim eindringen in die erdatmosphäre weil es eine höhere festigkeit haben größte meteorit der frei liegt,
in namibia der liegt einfach da wo er gefallen ist also ein kleines amphitheater drum herum gebaut liebt liegt da die diebstahlsicher ich weiß nicht wie viel tonnen er hat sechzig tonnen oder sowas,
ein riesen pfund,
das sind die eisenbahn heute also mit heute sind überbleibsel von kernen ehemaliger differenzierter körper.
Die durch kollision zerbrochen sind und seitdem in ihrem bestandteilen vorhanden sind noch.
Weil der kern einfach auch so schwer ist der verglüht dann einfach nicht der kommt dann einfach so runter und hat bestimmt mal ordentliches loch gemacht.
Steigeisen sind ein bisschen eine besonderheit wenn sie sich vorstellen sie sitzen auf dem mars und die erde explodiert was wird man erwarten an gestein,
neben dem was wir jetzt gerade schon besprochen haben könnte man material erwarten an der grenzschicht zwischen dem mantel also dem dem magma erdinneren,
dem eisen nickel ich würde also gestein und eisen vermischen.
Und ich mache das mechanisch nicht wie der zucker im café der nachher aufgelöst ist sondern diese eisen und diese gestein lassen sich nur mechanisch,
vermengen dann trennte sich wieder müssen sie das vorstellen statt eisen ist ein eisen eisenplatten unter drin wieso interessieren arbeit mineral körner.
In der regel olivia körner.
Also sind das objekte die mal unter beschuss gekommen sind oder unter explosionsbox bedingungen.
Das sind objekte die auch beim zerbrechen von so einem von seinem differenzierten körper entstanden sind sind selten nur etwa ein prozent aller fälle und funde sind solche steine eisen methode man nennt sie auch parasite nach einem herrn palast,
es gibt in schöneberg eine palast straße beim berliner naturforscher der der zurzeit von katharina der großen russischen akademie in sankt petersburg geforscht hat.
Es war noch einer von diesen naturforscher wie humboldt und solchen leuten die ab alles gemacht haben die haben wetterkunde gemacht und mineral logie und und und zoologin der ist eines tages ist der ist der gerufen worden nach einen ordner krassen royal,
das ist in sibirien dort hatten deutsche bergleute kohle bergleute waren ja viele europäer zu der zeit in russlands katharina hat ja viele reingeholt.
Die bergleute hatten einen klotz eisen gefunden achthundert kilo und die wussten ganz genau das gibt's nicht.
Sonst haben wir haben wir auch mit dem eisen erst hier wenn das einfach so rumliegt und die haben palast gerufen er sollte mal sagen was das ist und da kam dann von petersburg dahin und das war siebzehnhundert neunundvierzig und zu der zeit hat man wusste man nicht dass das außerirdisches material war.
Und was er gemacht hat ist er hat den dorfschmied kommen lassen und der dorfschmied hat mit hammer und meißel von dieser achthundert kilo masse stücke herunter geschlagen.
Und was dann passiert stellen sie sich so ein so ein verbund vor metall stein die mit die steine sind rausgebrochen das heißt diese objekte diese stücke von diesem mit rüttgers neujahrs,
sie haben also eine art metall skelett also piepsig wie man die anfühlt und daneben haben wir so eine röhrchen mit dem mineral dazu haben wir die bei uns in den sammlungen und palast hat stücke davon verschickt an viele akademie der wissenschaften in ganz europa,
hauptmeister liegt in moskau heute und er wusste nicht was es war aber er hat die beschrieben.
Das ist die erste beschreibung wissenschaftliche beschreibung eines meteoriten die wir haben ohne dass der palast wusste was er eigentlich beschreibt,
das war eine grundlage dafür dass dann später sich sich durchgesetzt hat dass es dass er die außerirdisches material war dass er erst viel später passiert siebenhundertvierundneunzig ist das publiziert worden von einem herrn club nie,
deutscher physiker aus wittenberg derart postuliert gesagt veröffentlicht das meteoriten außerirdisches material sind.
Das wurde nicht gerne gehört wenn man sowas sagt er wissenschaftscommunity das ist ja heute nicht anders und setze also viel widerspruch ein aber er hatte glück dass anfang des neunzehnten jahrhunderts fünf sechs sieben gab es einige meteoriten schauer in mitteleuropa die alle
von tausenden von leuten gesehen wurden auf dem augenzeugen dann setzte sich so langsam durch erst noch zu lebzeiten erlebt dass sich durchsetzen dass eine theorie,
anerkannt wurde also im mittelalter war natürlich klar ende der welt
da kommt da kommt ein feuer schweif und dann gibt es knallt und jetzt ist alles schluss strafe gottes und alles mögliche und.
Schöne geschichte der älteste erhaltene meteoriten fall europas vierzehnhundertzweiundneunzig kolumbus und der meteoriten voll vierzehnhundertzweiundneunzig runtergefallen,
hellichten tag mittags in einem kleinen örtchen damit inseln heim ins heim liegt im elsass nicht weit von freiburg auf der anderen rheinseite,
in weizenfeld dollar war bis basel zu hören und leuten hat hatten so viel angst vor dem metroid den haben sie in der dorfkirche angekettet.
Hallo.
Heute liegt am rathaus und gibt jedes jahr immer eine schöne kleine meteoriten börse die machen da was das ist immer ganz schön da,
viele händler und sammeln aber das war das war das war spätes mittelalter fährst und zweiundneunzig in der aufklärung gab es nicht gab es auch sehr interessante ideen leute dachten das sind vom blitz getroffen die vögel,
verkohlt weil's einfach schwarz ist oder vielleicht näherliegende vulkan ausbrüche.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem eisen und dem nickel das worum es da immer noch nickel dabei bin eigentlich hier so eisen so ein bisschen das kernelement ist.
Und da ist noch ganz viel dabei also das ist ja das ist ja eher sogar wundersam das in unseren krusten gestein überhaupt noch eisen und gold zum beispiel ist also,
alle schwere ist in den in den in den kern gesagt oder in den kern des dieser planetarium körper auch gold auch platin auch.
Wir haben ja sozusagen ein herz aus gold das kann man kann man so festhalten man kommt bloß nicht ran na ja.
Es würde sich lohnen das ist die fahne reinzustecken sozusagen.
Ein bisschen heiß da unten.
Allerdings ja es gibt natürlich also wie gesagt diese eisen eisen nickel.
Kerne sind inzwischen auch datiert worden das war zum beispiel so eine technische geschichte man wollte wissen wann haben sich die eigentlich gebildet wie schnell ging das eigentlich,
man sagt jetzt vier komma fünf sechs milliarden jahre sind der wahnsinnige spanne hat das vielleicht hundert millionen jahre gedauert bis die ersten sachen entstanden sind dann nochmal zweihundert millionen heute weiß man innerhalb von.
Dreißig vierzig millionen jahren bei der sonnensystem fertig und dazu muss man natürlich wissen wann sind denn solche kerne es erstmal entstanden und die sind sehr früh entstanden.
Die meteoriten erzählen uns einfach 'ne ganze menge darüber wie es sowohl in der entstehung des sonnensystems zu gange ging,
und auch was sozusagen eigentlich nicht dazu gehört und was was ich außerhalb unseres einzugsbereich noch so,
finden lässt welchen beitrag,
hat dann sozusagen diese meteoriten forschung und in dem zusammenhang natürlich auch diese sammlungen zu dem erkenntnisgewinn so in der letzten zeit,
konkret beigetragen gehört sind immer mal wieder in alles mögliche eingebunden ist so ein forschungsfeld was aufgegriffen wird
biologen etcetera astro geologen durfte das sehr interessant finden welche welche welche welche rolle spielt das so aus ihrer perspektive wie wie wichtig ist das nimmt die bedeutung zu,
so ein verkacktes feld.
Interesse nimmt momentan dramatisch zu wenig das vergleiche mit mit mit den letzten zehn jahren was aber massiv daran liegt dass wir ein sehr intensive missions vorherrscht zurzeit,
also die verschiedensten raumfahrt organisationen meistens zusammen weil weil das sehr teure sachen sind nehmen neue himmelskörper ins visier
und dann spielen die proben die wir haben die wir ja nicht nicht absichtlich genommen haben sondern die hier runtergefallen sind eine sehr große rolle in der vorbereitung solcher mission
wir haben ein paar ja schon angesprochen sind diese zu diesen typ steroiden kohlenstoff haltige da steht im mittelpunkt die frage nach dem leben,
rosetta war ja ähnlich zu einem kometen was in der nächsten zeit passieren wird sind sicherlich mission zu maß,
jetzt das nächste zu fokus und daimler monden um was über den mast zu lernen und da.
Auch eine mission der der jacke die da ja sich sehr darauf spezialisiert hat gerade.
Richtig diese jetzt in den startlöchern stehende zu den mars mohnen ist japanische kollegen jetzt fliegen werden wobei da dauert es eine kamera drauf das sind also in der regel sind das kooperation das macht heute keiner mehr alleine.
Da setze ich die kooperation vor die sich jetzt im prinzip zwei schon abgezeichnet hatte hatte ich ja auch mit trainingshose ausführlich darüber gesprochen wie es dazu kam und ich glaube man hat sich da jetzt ganz ganz lieb und geht jetzt gemeinsam ins all.
Ja genau das ist ja das wird dann immer spannender wenn die proben zurückkommen wem sie gehören.
Hallo.
Also die die metallhütte sind deswegen wichtig um um vorbereitungen zu treffen das material wird auch verwendet um zu gucken was erwarte ich denn da wie verhält sich das material komme ich mit meinem bohrer zum beispiel rein,
da gibt's ja manchmal eine überraschung überraschung wurden ja auch hat ja auch wohl rosetta erlebt als plötzlich die kometen oberfläche viele härter war als gedacht aber dies analog material spielt spielt eine große rolle wo es auch eine große rolle spielt,
ist gerade im bereich astro bio also die forschung die in die richtung organischer chemie.
Können wir was bestimmte und diese ursprüngliche methode die vorhin schonmal ansprach das sind auch diejenigen die organische substanzen enthalten und zwar keine,
irdischen sondern außerirdische da ist ein ganz großes feld werden gerade entstanden und wird sehr intensiv geforscht und natürlich proben lass dich.
Was können wir da separieren gucken uns aminosäuren an verschiedenste verschiedenste geschichten das ist ein ganz großes großes weites feld.
Was auch passiert ist er sprach da schon analog material,
viele verfahren bei den missionen sind ja spektrums komische verfahren die entweder aus dem orbit also aus einer umlaufbahn daten erzeugen oder bei ländern.
Und diese daten müssen immer kalibriert werden also die man kriegt immer irgendein spektrum sage ich mal und das muss aber aufgehängt werden wie die türen angel hängt muss ich wissen muss ich jetzt mal muss mal einen richtigen stein nehmen und gucken,
passt das passt das nicht was sagt mir das also da hat es eine große relevanz in letzter zeit immer stärker werden.
In dem zusammenhang also sprache ja schon an biologie ist ja auch so ein forschungsfeld was auch glaube ich,
immer größere bedeutung erhält eben teilweise durch ihm die mission teilweise weil's man einfach interessant findet und dort sich vielleicht mehr erkenntnisse noch,
erhofft und dann kommen wir auch mal so diese fragen mit wo kommt denn das leben,
eigentlich her inwiefern sind denn da die methodiken ein informationsgeber also hat man da schon was herausgefunden in dieser hinsicht,
oder was verspricht man sich zumindest davon.
Also man verspricht sich vor allen dingen von den frischen fällen solcher typen solche meteoriten klassen,
solcher kohlenstoff halte.
Was über die bausteine zu lernen also da sind jetzt keine da sind keine mikroben drin oder sowas sondern das sind das sind wirklich die die die urbane zustellen auch noch unter aminosäuren sozusagen alkoholiker tone was soll man es gibt meteoriten,
weniger aber es gibt welche wenn sie die in die hand nehmen die riechen nach benzin.
Reich sind die an organischen substanzen die hat also keine öl lappen gepackt oder sowas an die sind frisch runtergefallen und riechen nach benzin so organ organische reich sind die an diesen substanzen,
es gibt kollegen die für simulieren zum beispiel die entwicklung solcher organische moleküle,
also machen so kometen simulation züchten organische moleküle auf eis.
Was passiert eigentlich wenn ich sehe mich kohlenstoff stickstoff sauerstoff oder sowas bringt die da zusammen,
jetzt bestrahlt ich die energie muss man schon ein bisschen haben im u v strahlung nehmen oder sowas und machen das auf eis da ist kalt und jetzt gucken wir mal was passiert da gibt's irgendwie eine wechselwirkung mit dem eis
entstehen längere ketten das ist ja dann das was passiert wenn sich das entwickelt werden immer langkettige immer komplexer wie weit gehe ich denn finde ich sowas in meteoriten,
vergleiche ich diese sachen mit rosetta mission also da gibt's ja daten von juri,
von dem kometen organische substanzen ich sehe kurzkettigen ich sehe langkettige also irgendwie versuchen diese prozesse aufzuschlüsseln wie entwickelt sich das,
dann wird's komplexer denn stickstoff dazu kommt dann wird's komplexer weil schwefel dazu kommt noch komplexer bin voss vor dazu kommt aber das das ist so ein forschungsbereich in dem in dem gearbeitet wird.
Das erhält natürlich eine menge nahrung durch die jüngsten mission.
Ja natürlich also das ist immer ein ein teilbereich im fokus ist bei diesen missionen ja,
und das ist das ist auch das schöne wenn ich sage ich habe so hundertfünfzig meter heute im jahr auf den tisch nicht alles und gleich interessant natürlich da ist auch so ein bisschen was wie in jedem job das muss man halt auch mal mitmachen,
aber es kommt immer wieder welche die sehr spannend sind jetzt haben wir gerade einen so einen kohlenstoff reichen und wir selbst machen die organik nicht dass man den kollegen in diesem fall in münchen,
die dann den organischen teil machen wir machen die mineral hierzu müssen die chemie noch dazu und dann hat man eine schöne eine schöne story.
Was wir jetzt noch gar nicht angesprochen haben ist ja es gibt ja sozusagen auch noch das was nicht runtergefallen ist sondern was auch geholt wurde
vom mond dort ist man ja nun schon mehrere male gelandet und dann ist er auch das eine oder andere steinchen auch mal eingesackt worden und im prinzip war das ja was gar nicht.
Was das ausgelöst hat oder in inwiefern das sozusagen die moderne meteoriten forschung auch noch mit angeführt hat weil
vorher weiß ich nicht wie viel vorher schon so geforscht wurde an meteoriten also die größte erkenntnisgewinn war und dann eben das mond material kam,
ich schätze mal vom mond haben sie auch irgendwas rumliegen.
Ja ja also wir haben vom mond gibt es ja zwei zwei typen von material das eine ist das was sie ja gerade erwähnten also apollo material im wesentlichen,
ein bisschen russisches santa luna proben das war ein roboter mission die im programm noch aufgesammelt haben aber es sind dreihundertzweiundachtzig kilogramm haben die apollo mission auf die erde gebracht unterschiedliches material manches davon überhaupt noch nicht angeschaut.
Das sind die berühmten kisten im keller ja gibt's wirklich es gab letztes jahr eine aktion dass die nasa kollegen neues material geöffnet haben.
Weil sich dafür keiner interessiert hat oder weil man keine zeit hatte oder.
Ja das ist so ein bisschen der wissenschaft jetzt mal so ein auf und ab also bestimmte dinge rücken dann wieder in den fokus andere gefallen bisschen hin und her
runter mond war lange zeit nicht so,
im fokus man dachte man hat das eigentlich alles ganz gut verstanden und jetzt natürlich auch im sinne im im rahmen von kann man den besiedeln oder solche fragen kommt sowas wieder kommt etwas mehr in den in den in sichtbereich.
Also mission proben und wir haben meteoriten vom mond das hat man lange gedacht dass das gar nicht geht weil der montag der schwerkraft.
Das heißt man musste steine auf dieser berühmte entweicht geschwindigkeit,
beschleunigen sonst fällt er wie bei uns der apfel hochwerfen wieder runter und viele modellieren haben gesagt weißt du was die energie die dafür braucht um gestalten daraus zu schießen auf diese geschwindigkeit dann viel zu hoch der verdampft euch.
Das musst du dann korrigieren die modellieren als die erste miete meteorit gefunden wurde und das ist ein ein arktis gefunden worden man konnte ihn sehr gut identifizieren weil man ihn vergleichen konnte mit den apollo proben relativ leicht,
es gibt ein paar chemische signaturen noch aber organisch nötig unbedingt.
Man ist man ist sich da sehr schnell sehr sicher okay.
Man was man natürlich nicht hat bei den mond mit rhythmus hat keine geologische information man weiß nicht wo auf dem mond die herkommen.
Oder wie lange die unterwegs waren.
Das kann man raucht könnte man rauskriegen aber die sonnenbestrahlung alter die ich schon mal erwähnt aber.
Aber die werden auch auf dem mond seit bestrahlt.
Richtig,
das ist natürlich dann kommt drauf an wo sie lagen wann sie wann sie wann sie verdeckt sind die von tiefer rausgeschossen worden und das ist aber auch bei uns bei den apollo proben problem
es ist nicht klar dass wenn sie dann den stein aufheben dass der auch genau da entstanden ist könnte von ihrem impact krater gucken sich die motor an dahin geschossen worden,
vielleicht man weiß gar nicht von welchem das ist auch so eine sache.
Generell mal interessant zu sehen wie lange eigentlich dauert.
Es ist völlig unterschiedlich ist.
Aber man weiß ja wie lange es da lag auf der erde das weiß man schon so ne okay.
Kann man rauskriegen also es sind auch nicht so dass wir so der mond mit rausgeschossen und fliegt direkt zur erde.
Sondern fliegt erstmal irgendwo.
Irgendwie umlaufbahn und dann muss es eine sein die dieser erde kreuzt und dann das ist ja.
Also monty ist immer wieder wenn sie auf dem mond hochgucken in der sternenklaren nacht sehen sie die dunklen und die hellen bereiche,
die dunklen sind basalt und die hellen ist der sound der reguliert die oberfläche die sieht aus,
der staub wenn diese methode und diesem das sehen wir eine meteoriten wir kriegen das alte und wir kriegen jetzt nicht staub aber du sollst dann diese zerbrochene oberfläche zusammengeklebt die dinge sind aus wie waschbetonplatten,
also fragmente das ist der staub den sie vielleicht gerade ansprechen er dann verklebt wird durch ein glas was entsteht beim einschlag oder vorher schon fliegt dann auf die erde diese beiden typen von von dritten ganz grob kriegt man auf die erde man hat ja jetzt nicht viel neues gelernt sagen wir es mal so,
über die geologie des mondes die apollo proben sind ja schon schon natürlich wichtig.
Klar ich meine warum sollte man sich die meteoriten genauer anschauen wenn man selber schon da war und das alles so im urzustand sich angeguckt.
Neue was immer mal wieder diskutiert wird wir haben natürlich keine proben von der erde abgewandte mond seite.
Die rückseite des mondes zum beispiel kann es sein dass ein meteorit daherkommt spekulative aber es wirklich nicht wissen kann also nicht sagen da kommt das ding her war polo kann man das da hat er das aufgehoben.
Weil halt bisher alle lande also alle menschlichen lande missionen mit astronauten waren halt auf der zugewandten seite
die rückseite ist ja jetzt erst vor den chinesen das erste mal mit dem rover dort bedient worden aber die
wir haben ja keine sample rittern von daher muss man wahrscheinlich ein bisschen warten aber ist denn wenn man jetzt sozusagen sich das original material anschaut und dann insofern auch ein sonderfall und sich dann eben einen mond meteorit der ist also tatsächlich auf die erde geschafft hat anschaut,
gut da weiß man okay ist mond aber hat ja im prinzip auch eine wunderbare vorlage um mal so ganz genau anzuschauen so ist es vorher,
und so sieht's aus wenn's bei uns gelandet ist im prinzip auch so ein objekt wo man dann mal überprüfen kann die eigenen thesen mit was ich denn nun beim einschlag so ändert das wurde sicherlich getan.
Ja klar also es ist wie gesagt wie gesagt wenn ich jetzt mond basalt nehme untypisch dann bei salzwasser finden können es gibt natürlich auch die erde auch beiseite aber hier haben die alle,
meistens wasser in kontakt gekommen mund beiseite sind knochentrocken ein wunderschönes gefüge also wirklich wirklich was auf der schönste was fürs auge sozusagen,
und da sieht man wie wenig jetzt sozusagen der eintritt in die erdatmosphäre macht ja frisch erhalten nichts passiert damit wenn man ein bisschen sonderseiten weil die natürlich,
einiges an druck gesehen haben als sie daraus geschossen wurden die müssen auf zweieinhalb kilometer pro sekunde beschleunigt werden dann können sie das gravitationswellen des mondes verlassen,
dabei kriegen die einiges ab das heißt der druck in die temperaturen gehen hoch und das ist das was mineralien nicht so besonders mögen im extremfall schmelzen sieht,
vorher aber weichen sie dem druck aus kennen das mit der mit der berühmten wassertropfen auf der herdplatte rund verringert also die die oberfläche das beste was mineral machen kann es wird würfel,
rund ganz nicht aber es wird ein würfel das kubisch alle ecken alle winkel gleich lang,
und dieses wissen so an der hochdruck phasen die dabei entstehen das wissen glaube ich ganz interessant wenn man sich so einen erdkunde buch anguckt und zieht die erde größte mantel kern woher weiß man das eigentlich.
Einmal reingebohrt bis zum kern oder und das sind das eine ecken ne das sind erkenntnisse aus der physik und zwar haben die physiker beobachten seismische wellen erdbeben willen,
die an der oberfläche ausgelöst werden durch die erde durchlaufen und unten wieder aufgefangen werden,
wenn man sich diese wellen anguckt die geschwindigkeit dieser wellen dann merkt man dies nicht gleichmäßig,
sondern die hat nämlich an diesen an diesen grenzen die ich gerade nannte ist und gibt noch mehr bin ich plötzlich schneller langsamer schneller langsamer und schneller heißt das material dichter,
und weniger schnell heißt es wird.
Locker und so hat man das hat man diese diese grenzen und man weiß dass im mantel also tief unten hat dieses berühmte mineral olivia was ich hin vorhin schon erwähnte.
Das muss im erdmann würfelförmig werden seine erdoberfläche nicht.
Durch den druck und es hat ein australischer physiker zum ersten mal postuliert ein herr ringbloots ringbloots und dieses mineral heißt ringoutfit hat nie einer gesehen.
Hallo.
Bis vor kurzem man hat es aber gefunden und zwar in meteoriten.
Der meteoriten entsteht es aber nicht durch diesen statischen druck in zig kilometer tiefe sondern durch den kurzen druck beim einschlag,
herausgeschossen wird das ist also ein bisschen hoch hochdruck mineral ist viel an an meteoriten gemacht worden man kann die experimentell machen aber natürlich ist dieser regenboot zum ersten mal,
in meteoriten gefunden wurden paar jahren hat man ihn dann tatsächlich das erste mal irdisch gefunden.
Sie gerade hier so ein paar bilder wäre das oliven halt wie der name wahrscheinlich schon nahelegt grün ist ist er denn dieses ring wo es dann bläulich.
Das quietscht leader ist ja ja das ist blau lila das ist ja richtig es gibt noch eine phase dazwischen die heißt das war der.
Hallo.
Immer diese schönen namen aber irgendwo ist auch noch was fürs auge ja genau das ist.
Aber so ein kit gibt.
Dann gibt es noch nicht,
wir haben jetzt gerade wo wir wo wir beim mond waren es gibt auf dem mond an mineralien feldstab dort das gibt's auf der erde auch das ist in so einem bergmännisch der name eigentlich fällt spart und,
der mond ist extrem kalzium reich und dieses dieser feld spart auf dem mond der ist viel kalzium reicher als er auf der erde ist und hochdruck.
Hoher druck ändert sich auch dieser kalzium reiche fehlstart in einen hochdruck modifikation die haben wir letztes jahr gefunden in einem mond meteorit,
da haben wir in der tat den mineral neu benannt das ist ein relativ komplizierter prozess das zu tun gibt es eine kommission.
Der internationalen meterologischen heißt es immer genau und da müssen sie bestimmte christoph grafische daten chemie und sowas abliefern,
das ist ein sehr kleines mineral und das war aber nicht so nicht so leicht aber das haben wir jetzt.
Und wie heißt es.
Benannt nach einem amerikanischen kollegen der heißt das heißt villa wilhelm mit heißt das tonnen wilhelm mit,
ja weil wilhelm mit gab's schon muss man in vorne vorsetzen das ist ein verdienter kollege der lange bei der nasa warnt ein dickes buch über den mond geschrieben hat.
Und das fanden alle angemessen dass der auch noch mal eins kriegt schiebt man sich nicht selber so nach vorne.
Ja das war das war das war das das darf man gar nicht mehr darf nicht nachts nicht sehen dass sie selbst benennt man kann seine kollege hast gefunden und der darf sich nach mir benennen aber das.
Na vielleicht haben sie ja noch glück.
Das war relativ kompliziert aber es ist gut das ist montag mond meteorit in diesem fall in diesem fall was ja völlig anders ist mars meter anderes thema das ist woher weiß man dass sie vom mars kommen.
Genau da wollte ich gerade drauf zu sprechen kommen nachdem wir den mond jetzt abgeklappert haben also maß mit rüden,
sagt sich immer so leicht also heiß halt einfach da ist dann tatsächlich wasser vom mars abgesprintet worden durch irgendeinen anderen impact in der regel
und wie der zufall es so wollte ist ja nicht so super wahrscheinlich dass man jetzt ausgerechnet also keine ahnung wie wahrscheinlich das ist aber,
naja muss auf jeden fall gut treffen und irgendwann dann halt lernen und auch noch gefunden werden.
Das muss alles zusammenkommen und wir wissen aber dass der vorteil dass,
in der nordafrikanischen wüste seit zwanzig fünfundzwanzig jahren so systematisch gesucht worden ist seitdem ist die die die anzahl von maß meteoriten sprunghaft in die höhe geschnellt also ich sage jetzt mal wir haben hundert stück oder sowas schienen,
ein daumen gepeilt.
Seit wann weiß man denn überhaupt also seit wann konnte man denn überhaupt erst wissen dass es vom mars kam weil man war ja noch nicht da.
Richtig das ist der große nachteil wir können das nicht vergleichen deswegen gibt es auch nur so eine gewisse indizien kette die kann man jetzt überzeugend finden oder nicht ich sag mal folgendes amerikaner hatten ja,
zwei länder auf dem mars walking eins und biking zwei und diese viking sondern die haben die maße wäre analysiert der mann hat eine atmosphäre sehr dünne atmosphäre aber er hat eine,
und es macht uns alle atmosphären analyse oder was weiß ich c o zwei stickstoff sauerstoff aber auch die ganzen edelgase krypto und gesehen und sowas also der eine teil des puzzles,
und der zweite teil des war das amerikanische kollegin in einem vermuteten maß meter rücken,
im mikroskop gesehen haben dass der kleine glas kügelchen enthält schmelzkäse kügelchen murmeln wo viel kleiner,
entstanden beim einschlag macht ein bisschen material geschmolzen dann haben sie gesehen diese glaskugeln die haben lufteinschüsse,
so wie so eine alte blumenvase die nicht richtig abgeschreckt ist oder altes fenster oder sowas dann haben sie die raus diese kügelchen aufgelöst das gas entwich,
uns wurde analysiert und zwar eins zu eins marsatmosphäre.
Was man wüsste durch die viking mission die so mitte der siebziger jahre dort gelandet sind.
Das waren das sind so diese puzzleteile und dann gibt's einen gab's einen papern natur- und,
wo man sagt in ordnung das paar dressur erklärt es gab diesen einschlag auf der maße fläche dieses gestein was rausgeschossen wurde wurde so heiß teilbereiche ausgeschmolzenen.
Faire eingeschlossen.
Abgeschreckt wurden richtig.
Wie so ein bernstein.
So das ist so der eine,
in die zimmerpreis der zweite ist ich habe ja schon gesagt es sind fast alles mathematische gesteine das heißt die waren früher mal flüssig sind bei einem vulkanausbruch entweder ausgeschlossen oder oder richtig rotiert,
und wenn man das alter dieser gesteine bestimmt dann wundert man sich wir haben ja immer vier komma fünf sechs milliarden aber ja gesprochen die haben so dreihundert millionen,
spannweite jetzt,
sehr jung und es gibt also einen richtig alten von der alten maßkrug die frage war wo in unserem sonnensystem gab's denn vor so relativ kurzer zeit noch aktiven vulkan.
Und das muss ein großer körper sein der in der lage war lange hitze zu produzieren viel hitze um zu schmelzen sind wir bei zweitausend grad oder sowas,
da kommt eigentlich nur der maße in frage wer kennt das große olympus mons volkan feld und das ist da ist man sich jetzt schon,
relativ relativ sicher aber in der tat es gibt so ist es so eine indizien kette und wir müssen hin und was holen nur etwas vergleichen können.
Ist es eigentlich vorstellbar dass oder gibt's sogar entsprechende funde die das was von venus oder sogar mehr kur zu uns kommt wahrscheinlich eher unwahrscheinlich.
Das wird immer wieder diskutiert vor allen dingen mehr kur venus ist extrem unwahrscheinlich aufgrund der hohen schwerkraft unter sehr dichten atmosphäre das spielt auch eine rolle tatsächlich wenn das material rausgeschossen wird kollidiert mit diesem atmosphären molekül.
Wie ist denn die schwerkraft auf der venus.
Wahrscheinlich etwa die der erde um ungefähr also es dürfte nicht nicht also auf jeden fall deutlich höher als auf dem mars,
man kann sich das so pi mal daumen merken die erde hat zehn kilometer pro sekunde fünf maß zweieinhalb mond.
Ja gut aber ich meine wenn ihr etwas einschlägt auf der venus dann fliegt doch auch mal was weg oder nicht.
Die frage ist ob es rauskommt modellieren sagen die wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr gering merkur ist anderes anderes thema merkur das müsste gehen.
Aber es ist halt sehr nah an der sonne.
Das ist der große staubsauger der da sitzt natürlich mit mit schwerkraft und und das ist aber es ist immer wieder diskutiert worden.
Also mit anderen worten da gibt's nichts.
Nichts gesichertes richtig.
Nichts gesichert ist okay.
Also merkur wie gesagt wird immer mal wieder diskutiert wenn wenn ein meteorit auftaucht der denn keine schublade was sage ich mal und.
Können wir nicht muss mal kurz sein.
So ungefähr es gab ja darf man auch nicht vergessen es ist ja nicht noch nicht lange her dass vernünftige merkur daten gab also die merkur mission der planet der vermutlich am spätesten komplett kartiert wurde marina,
mission und jetzt gerade erst wieder ein bisschen ins ins in den fokus gerückt im erkoren ist eben sehr heiß aufgrund der hohen großen nähe zur sonne.
Und wird demnächst auch noch mal einen fokus geraten ist ja gerade noch eine zweite mission die columbo mission unterwegs braucht noch ein paar jahre und dann wird's nochmal interessant.
Da haben wir zum beispiel auch wenn man es noch ergänzen darf kollegen die die bei uns die metallhütte durch gemessen haben mit infrarot spektrometer kollegen aus münster für die mission die haben so spektrometer an bord.
Weil die sozusagen schon mal eine erwartungshaltung haben wollen was man vielleicht finden könnte was vielleicht passen könnte.
Es gibt ideen was dafür für gestein an der oberfläche zu finden ist.
Aber trotzdem ist eigentlich die wahrscheinlichkeit dass jetzt in ihrer sammlung schon irgendwas liegt was von merkur kommt aus den genannten gründen,
eher gering sehr gering aber das heißt ja nicht dass es nicht möglich ist ist ja immer alles möglich sag mir diese,
es es wird immer mehr gefunden man hat ja eigentlich relativ gute indikatoren weil jeder
eintritt der stattfindet hinterlässt ja im prinzip eine relativ klare sichtbare spur,
die man vielleicht nicht immer aber ziemlich oft
sehen kann und weil es ja auch nicht nur so ein punkt ist sondern damit ja eine bewegung eine geschwindigkeit eine richtung etcetera verbunden ist
müsste man doch eigentlich durch eine konsequente beobachtung des himmels auch dort chancen haben noch mehr material frisches material zu finden gibt's da so einen
beobachtungs netzwerk.
Gibt es und zwar hier in mitteleuropa das heißt feuer kugel netzwerk das sind wirklich interessierte.
Bürgerinnen und bürger die kameras auslösen in der dämmerung,
und morgens macht ihr wieder zu und man hat alles was ich dann am himmel bewegt hat dokumentiert also natürlich,
die erde rotiert und hat die spuren der sterne aber völlig klar unterscheidbar von einem von einem von einem eintretender zum beispiel das gleiche wird auch in australien gemacht da weiß ich das von kollegen gibt weltweit einige kollege marokko machen das von zwischen kollegen,
das ist weltweit.
Nicht mehr selten dass sowas gemacht wird viel also ganz vieles damit noch nicht gefunden worden vieles nämlich was in die erdatmosphäre eintritt verglüht kommt gar nicht an.
Dann ist kommt hinzu dass das aufsuchen und das auffinden von solchen objekten gar nicht so leicht ist,
das berechnen wo ist der denn runtergekommen das sind so viele parameter und erreicht ja eine halbe bogen minute dann ist man wie viel kilometer weiter aber es passiert natürlich es gab jetzt letztes jahr einen fall.
Ähnlich wie in binz viele dash cams oder sicherheitskarte ras die das dokumentiert haben an der nordsee,
in holland belgien deutschland dennemark gesehen worden der schweiz,
und dann ist sogar ein stück gefunden worden in der nähe von flensburg im vorgarten.
Vierundzwanzig komma fünf gramm also ja genau und das ist natürlich so dass spielen sie lieber lotto ne das ist,
das ist eine spektakuläre geschichte dann und auch noch ein spannender und kollegen.
Die werden sich ja gewohnheit haben dass er so ein so ein hollywood moment wenn dann auf einmal so 'ne wissenschaftler scharf vor der tür stehen sagt guten tag wir müssen mal vor.
Durchsuchen.
Ja also das ist passiert fünfundachtzig gab's das damals stand die mauer ja noch da hatten meteorit erlaubter weise die zonengrenze überquert,
kam von westen hannover über die grenze sozusagen da oben in der altmark,
salzwedel und da stand ein junge stand abends neunzehn uhr oder so aber es war schon dunkel stand am fenster sah er den schweif und dann macht es klappt.
Ist vorne pappel von baum geflogen,
er durfte abends aber nicht mehr raus weil schon dunkel war dann am nächsten morgen mit seinem lehrer da hin und die haben wirklich außerdem dreißig gramm stücke oder sowas am fuß der pappe gefunden.
Unterstück ist dann nach berlin gekommen das war noch zu ddr-zeiten und liegt auch im museum ausgestellt und ich glaube der junge durfte sich damals einen glitzernden kristall dafür aussuchen.
Aber während denn das generell erstrebenswert so aus so mit diesem feuer kugel netzwerk was,
richtiges zu bauen oder lohnt sich das nicht ist das jetzt mehr so liebhaberei und okay nett vielleicht kommt mal was dabei raus aber jetzt konsequent alles was da einschlägt so zu tracken dass man vielleicht,
durch genaue berechnungen der ganzen flug parameter sehr schnell,
fundorte ausmachen kann ist das überhaupt erstrebenswert oder ist das so ja okay wenn's passiert ist gut aber braucht man nicht.
Also es gibt kollegen die machen das also physiker astrophysiker diese diese bahn parameter rechnen das sind aber nicht viele die das tun also das ist jetzt kein würde jetzt mal so die die anzahl von meteoriten nicht signifikant erhöhen die wir haben.
Was ja ab und zu mal passiert ist dass satelliten sowas aufnehmen.
Die schauen ja von oben herab.
Die von oben drauf schauen sie also zu nehmen den blitz sehen der dann in der oberen atmosphäre passiert da sagt mir nichts was unten passiert aber so kriegt man schon sie muss halt gewisse größe haben das muss schon im auflösens vermögen des des athleten natürlich sein,
gab es immer wieder diskussionen was passiert eigentlich mit objekten die erdoberfläche nicht erreichen aber kurz kurz vor der erdoberfläche explodieren die berühmte tusk ereignis in sibirien,
man weiß da ist irgendwas alles ist blatt an bäumen ob es mit ritter kein krater kann gar nichts und solche sachen könnten auch für unsere athleten,
in dieser größenordnung detektiert werden es gab ja ein fröhliches neue bänder da ist ja so ein objekt form eintritt in die atmosphäre von satelliten entdeckt worden.
Also noch im anflug auf die erde.
Und dann ist der eingetragen in die drogen in die erdatmosphäre und dann hat er ein pilot einer glaube holländischen linien maschine hat ihn an sich vorbeifliegen sehen.
Noch so als also schon als feuer kugel dann.
Schon als als als und dann ist der eingeschlagen im sudan,
das hat man rechnen können weil man ihn schon vorher gesehen hatte das ist aber der einzige fall den ich kenne und wir sind auch stücke aufgesammelt worden.
Alma sitter heißt er ist eine bahnstation im sudan die in der nähe war die kriegen ja meistens namen von irgendwelchen.
Orten ja.
Orten in der nähe und aber das war mal eine spannende geschichte wollen schon vorher vorne vornherein sehen konnte da kommt einer rein,
ich wusste nicht genau auf das überlebt aber hatte und das mit hier rot gelandet.
Was hat durchaus vorstellbar dass wir jetzt durch die zunehmende verbreitung von kameras und auch satelliten,
was ich denke sowas wie starlink das projekt jetzt von space-x also wirklich mit hunderten,
von von satelliten da draußen tausende von satelliten da draußen ist dass man natürlich auf einmal eine ganz andere coverage bekommen könnte so denn die entsprechende sensorik und rückmeldung vorhanden ist.
Kriegt man mit sicherheit das problem ist natürlich auch dass jemand da hinstellt in der atmosphäre desto höher wird die bedrohung durch solche objekte und das ist ein sehr ernsthafte geschichte der auch mikrometer die dann da,
einfach mal durch die wand fliegen ne also das ist,
dann kommen die vielleicht dreißig vierzig kilometer pro sekunde an und die haben halt keinen energieschub wie die enterprise oder sowas dann dann gehen die dann gehen die da durch.
Was muss man sich dennoch für gedanken machen wir hatten ja vorhin schon so diese ganze frage mit organischem material was damit,
einhergeht und die frage so nach dem
nach dem leben wenn jetzt bei künftigen missionen jetzt noch mehr solche samples geholt werden wie wir das jetzt haben es ist ja gerade unterwegs und wird noch eine weile
dauern und dann hoffentlich unversehrt hier irgendwie ankommen,
da holt man sich ja dann sozusagen material rein wenn man das jetzt dann in seinem ursprünglichen zustand untersuchen
möchte dann muss man ja auch verhindern dass es hier zu weiteren,
kontamination kommt und eine ähnliche problematik gibt's prinzip auch für missionen woanders hin weil irgendwann weiß ich komme mal auf dem mond mist irgendwas tolles und stellt irgendwann fest,
haben die apollo mission da schon eingebracht was spielt es für eine rolle.
Also spielt eine sehr große rolle bei der planung solche sogenannten sample return mission also.
Was bringt man hin was holt man zurück stichwort heißt bio herr also die bedrohung durch potentielle bedrohung durch durch,
biologische signaturen von mikroben bis hin zu was viren oder sowas ja,
jede solche mission bevor die startet durchläuft ein pro programm wo wissenschaftlich draufgeschaut wird und zwar von extern nicht von der von der veranstaltenden rumgesessen schaft selbst sondern von anderen.
Was was was ist potenziell gefährlich,
wie muss das das space geschafft auch design sein welche anforderung hat es im vorfeld im nachfeld was machen wir denn die proben zurückkommen,
man kann spekulieren was man erwartet man kann sagen unwahrscheinlich wie viel viel zu heiß auf dem körper als dass da irgendwie was passieren kann aber am ende wenn die probe hier ist sie hier,
also wir sind diese aufbewahrungs orte wie sind was für rein raum klassen hab ich was für virenschutz geschichten habe ich und da spielt eine riesenrolle bei der diskussion solcher solcher mission gerade jetzt maß,
schon mal angedeutet vor das ist das nächste was was angeflogen wird als sample return und,
übrigens ist das neunundsechzig nicht anders gemacht worden als apollo flog und material mitbrachte muss man ja auch nicht was was zurückkommt,
da waren ähnliche befürchtungen oder ähnliches sicherheitsmaßnahmen sind haben sie als als nicht erforderlich herausgestellt aber natürlich muss man das erstmal machen,
und wir wissen auch dass diese physicality ist jetzt noch in houston existieren am johnson spacer sicherlich nicht mehr so ausgelegt sind wie wir das heute können das heißt es wird alles neu gebaut,
gucken sich irgendwelche viren filme an outbreak oder sowas dann laufen da endlich.
Oh mir fällt nur so ein ganz alter klassiker ein andromeda tödlicher staub.
Sehr schön sehr schön ja.
Ganz toller film.
Das ist ein thema was sehr hoch hoch gehandelt wird und diese mission brauchen auch freigaben sonst sonst von diesem sektor,
ich habe einmal so eine runde mitgemacht da sitzt man dann mit mikrobiologen pathologen medizinern physikern chemikern geowissenschaftler und erklärt sich gegenseitig so die sicht,
lernt vokabeln und er ist schon spannend so so so über die grenzen.
Beantworten es bleibt spannend in ihrem feld gibt keinen,
zeichnet sich nicht ab dass weniger proben reinkommen zeichnet sich nicht weniger ab das nicht neue fragen aufgeworfen werden ich bin so ein bisschen durch mit meinen fragen und was worauf man nochmal,
sprechen kommen sollte.
Also wichtig ist das was wir momentan wirklich sehr stark erleben berührt hat es ja schon mal sind diese kooperation mit mit missionswerke,
mit drin hängen selbst ein bisschen weniger auch ein bisschen design natürlich aber,
ich glaube das wird wird in zukunft nicht weniger werden sondern eher mehr werden und das steht ja auch nicht still die nächsten mission stehen ja in den in den startlöchern und gerade mit dem drk kooperation auch darüber was,
passiert damit material wenn es hierhin kommt zum beispiel wenn es nach berlin kommt also könnt ihr das auch bewahren können wir das aufbewahren.
Ich muss ja irgendwo hin.
Muss irgendwohin und an eine regel wenn's zurückkommt ist dass sie nicht irgendwie aber ein normaler schrank in das,
genau die sachen über die wir gerade besprochen haben die isar ist sehr daran interessiert eine europäische.
Das ding heißt schon stories also ein aufbewahrungsort zu bauen weil wir haben's ja vorhin schon gesagt wenn das kooperationen sind ist ja schön wenn da jeder geld einzahlt aber irgendwie muss ja auch muss das ja als ich irgendwie zurückzahlen und wenn's proben sind,
man kann es auch gut sein dass das material nach europa kommt.
Das heißt es wird ein neuer standort aufgebaut werden oder es ist noch in der diskussion okay.
Das sind gerade diskussionen die laufen können wir ein ein hier hat großes interesse daran und das wird zumindest bereit sind und nicht dass irgendwelche kollegen sagen ja ihr könnt ja gar nicht wir nehmen's auch mal ab.
Ja ok man will sozusagen bereit sein und sowas muss natürlich immer sehr langfristig
geplant werden weil es muss ja im zweifelsfall auch langfristig gebaut werden die city was für anforderungen müsste denn so ein ort haben was für anforderungen haben sie denn zu sagen derzeit im naturkundemuseum die jetzt so über normale lagerung hinausgehen.
Also wir werden momentan nicht in der lage solche sachen mal so mit mit biosignatur behafteten proben sicher aufzubewahren das muss das kann momentan glaube ich kaum einer,
es muss gebaut werden.
Also muss richtig noch was erfunden werden so.
Das muss gemacht ja das muss vor allen dingen definiert werden das ist so ein bisschen ähnlich wie mit den standards die sieben für die werten banken ansprachen am anfang auch das muss definiert werden vor was wollen wir uns denn schützen also kann immer noch schiefgehen wissen wir ja alle man,
sein dass man nicht alles im griff kriegt aber was können wir denn tun.
Was zeichnet sich da jetzt so ab was war so kellergewölbe irgendwie.
Also wir sind ganz ganz ganz am anfang ich habe glaube ich noch gar keine über unterirdisch nachgedacht kann auch passieren aber schlechte er.
Im ruhrgebiet gibt's ja schon einiges was man dort nutzen könnte.
Aber das ist das eine diskussion jetzt.
Ich weiß nicht ob sie auch vor verstrahlung zum beispiel geschützt werden muss oder sowas das wäre.
Das war mal.
Argument für unterirdisch.
Ja das war natürlich eine befürchtung von mondgeschichte und ich kann nur sagen die meteoriten die wir kennen sie strahlen ungefährlich,
da gibt's mineralische mineral die viel viel strahlung intensiver sind also alle uran mineralien zum beispiel pech blenden oder sowas die wir haben die sind in in,
gesicherten schränken.
Also weil die jetzt selber strahlen aber dass die selber durch strahlung jetzt noch mal eigentlich unsinnig man man holt sich das sozusagen aus dem weltall da ballert die ganze zeit drauf da ist es ja hier auf der erde eigentlich an sich schon mal sehr viel besser beschützt.
Ja ja das ist aber ein strahlenschutz ist natürlich ein thema das ist klar völlig klar beide mineralien haben wir das häufig ist ja noch viel lustiger wenn die mineral zerfallen regen ja wieder andere man muss aufpassen dass sie nicht den schrank anregen.
Ach so dass man da irgendwas reinstellt und dann fängt auf einmal alles an um zu.
Ich sehe schon da ist noch musik im spiel ich sage vielen vielen dank für die ausführung das war,
spannende einblicke in die welt der meteoriten hat mir sehr gefallen ich hoffe euch da draußen hat's auch gefallen das war's heute mit raum zeit.